ladies and gentlemen welcome to a
special edition of tim cast irl tonight
is joe biden's state of the union
address and we had a great super chat
from someone they said they said bless
the speech writers for uh joe biden
because what are they going to have him
say it has been an awfully brutal year
we've had more covet deaths in the past
year than the year before under trump
inflation is consistently breaking
records we now have
a new war one of the most significant
serious wars breaking out in europe so
um
i guess joe biden will do his best to
keep morale up i don't want to be such a
a downer and be like all joe biden can
do is depress everybody maybe we'll see
him pull through but uh that's going to
be starting at 9 pm eastern so we will
be talking about news a lot of crazy
stories belarus has told nato that
they're pushing russia towards world war
three but get this they've also voted on
a resolution
voted on or passed
now they are no longer a a a a nuclear
neutral country they are now a nuclear
country nuclear state whatever whatever
you call it they are allowing russia to
stage nuclear weapons in belarus ukraine
has already accused belarus of invading
from the north the u.s says well we
haven't seen any proof of that but
regardless it seems like things are
absolutely getting
they're getting really really crazy so
here's what we're going to do we've got
a bunch of people who are hanging out
tonight we're going to be just chilling
having a good time we're actually having
a drinking game
we have a bunch of beers
from our friends over at old 690 brewery
in virginia great people good beer and
we are going to drink every time uh we
have this this amazing bingo bingo card
bingo list every time something happens
we'll make a mark and then take a sip of
beer and we'll see who wins so this is
uh all the work of kian bextie lauren
southern seamus coughlin uh i don't know
were you down there ian or negatively no
no he was sleeping and they came with a
lot of really great jokes i participated
a little bit and so there's things like
if joe biden says man
if he says our democracy if he
plagiarizes i think you guys spelled
plagiarize wrong good well i didn't
spell it no uh walks the wrong way
tells a fake story yep uh gas lights
curses fake tough tough guy sticks so
we'll get in all that stuff but uh
because it's kind of a special night i'm
gonna do this real quick we have a great
sponsor virtual shield i'm i'm super
excited that they've sponsored the show
as long as they did for those who don't
know they're the first sponsor i've ever
had on youtube they've been with us all
through everything we've ever done and
they're here now so go to surfing
internet safe if you would like to get a
virtual private network service this is
a basic layer of security for you as you
browse the internet if you've been
paying attention to the show and the
news you can see why it's so important
because the january 6 committee and
other government agencies have been
given your i shouldn't say your data but
given the data of journalists of of
politicians of high-profile political
individuals
by these these digital by these isps and
by these phone companies so these
politicians just go to say
we'll just call it an isp and they say
give us the phone records of this
politician and the phone company says
okay they just do it no warrants no
nothing
it's it's an extreme violation of your
rights so there's one thing you can do
if you're concerned about this because
it does affect everybody you look at
what's happening with the capitol police
and the intelligence agency they've
become and they're spying on people
whatever
you go to surfing internet safe surfing
internet safe sign up for virtual shield
download their product and this will
give you a basic layer of security it
sends all of your data through an
encrypted channel so people who are
trying to spy on you have a much harder
time of doing it no security is perfect
but this is an excellent way to make
sure you're staying safe at least a
little bit so again surfing internet
safe check out their website you get you
get a deal if you go there it's a
lifetime 50 discount by signing up right
now and uh again shout out to virtual
shield for making this show happen
sticking with me and all my content and
channels from when i started youtube
till now they rock these are the
companies you guys should be supporting
that being said let's let's get a quick
round of introductions joining us in
this very we have a lot of people today
we've got a couple journalists someone
who has been covering the freedom convoy
we got kian baxter you want to introduce
yourself yeah absolutely yeah uh um can
you pull your mic up a little bit yeah
there you go
getting real close i'm a journalist from
canada obviously i was covering the
freedom convoy um and i'm the
editor-in-chief of thecountersignal.com
and our job in canada is to combat
the propaganda that comes out of the
state broadcaster uh the canadian
broadcasting corporation it's a 1.5
billion dollar
justin trudeau propaganda arm so uh
that's what we do is we we publish
everything that they don't want
canadians and uh people around the world
to see uh when it comes to news about
canada so i uh yeah i'm happy to be here
it's exciting it's gonna be fun i got we
we have two canadians who are going to
help comment on what joe biden is doing
southern right i'm not okay with that if
you haven't noticed canadians have
massively infiltrated the uh american
conservative political movement so this
is what's up with that we're starting to
take over tim castle what are you
talking about canadian
canadians what canadians have
infiltrated the american political
commentaries
tweeted out the only good thing about
the freedom convoy and justin trudeau's
like overreach of power is now canadian
commentators are finally talking about
their own country
that's fair that is hilarious yes i'm
lauren southern canadian journalist
filmmaker kian and i have actually made
a movie together yes which one the mass
graves hoax
yeah you should watch it some spicy
content
but yeah i guess uh i guess sheamus
throw it over to me so uh shane i
mentioned an american an actual real
american who comments on america
from the chicago area back there so i
comment on politics i do cartoons if you
guys want to check me out at freedom
tunes we release animated cartoons every
single week sometimes twice a week and
we're gonna have a pretty funny one up
about the the state of our
military in light of the crisis uh with
ukraine and russia i think it's going to
be pretty funny and yeah i'm here to
talk with some friends and some
canadians
uh about joe biden canadians
uh well my name is in ian is in canada
i'm gonna look at that joke drop it yeah
that's before i toss it over the lids
i'm going to give you a couple of
corrections from yesterday we mentioned
the gallipoli campaign uh england and
australia invaded gallipoli i said it
was in world war ii well they they
beachheaded on it it was world war one
and secondly we were talking about alexi
uh the silly archipelagos his name was
celiac one of the russian hero that
prevented world war iii is one of three
commanders and a sub i said that he he
got orders to fire nuclear missiles what
actually happened was uh they were
underwater and cut off from or they
didn't have any orders from moscow there
were depth charges and two of the
commanders on the sub wanted to fire
nuclear torpedoes and he said no wait
for
orders from moscow then eventually they
came to the surface and realized they
weren't at war and that he had prevented
what could have been a catastrophe so
i had to happy to get that out and you
know what in the name of correcting
potential misinformation i referenced
men against fire last night which is
contested it's not gospel so
thank you just wanted to say that yeah
are we are we doing all our fact checks
yeah lauren there would be too much time
if you started doing yourself enough
no i said that uh the australian
politician didn't say new world order
she 100 said new world australian the
australian health administrator when she
was saying i'm going to create right
yeah so
and the ukrainian
member of parliament said we're fighting
for the new world war the other day
yes we got lydia president very
interesting stuff tonight i don't have
any time
i've not pressed any of the wrong
buttons yet we'll get there we have a
cool new shot to try out i'm very
excited for it i'm going to crack a
window open
yeah yeah so this is our uh yeah oh look
at this look at all those nonsense there
goes tim walking behind ian it's so cool
how do i look down right i'm looking
down at who's below me on that it's like
a pretty bunch you're looking down at me
yeah it's great i'm excited it's gonna
be fun
all right tim's back what up fun so uh
man it's it's this is a special episode
we're probably gonna go really long
hanging out here so we got a bunch of
beers i think we're gonna need more
might i can't i can't i i almost never
drink so i have like a beer and i i've
imagined that's the limit that i'll have
is a b or absolutely
but i i just want to make sure everyone
is aware
there's been there's been a bunch of
issues with uh live streams that have
you know commented on public broadcasts
state of union dresses
so i uh did my due diligence i contacted
youtube and i said can we comment on
broadcasting the state of the union
address they said yes they've they've
they've worked really hard to make sure
that these false takedowns don't happen
because what will happen is joe biden is
speaking but his words are being
broadcast unlike every network so what
happens is the automated system will be
like hey this sounds like cnn right now
and they'll take people down
we are going to be using the official
white house broadcast we have 50 minutes
and 56 seconds until it goes live and
the other thing just to make sure is i
said we're also going to be playing a
drinking game where every time biden
does something that we expect him to do
or maybe not we'll take a drink is that
allowed on live streams and we i was
told uh definitively of course yeah
exclamation point and and uh very
cheerfully so i said all right and i'll
also mention this a we drink responsibly
here i mean i'll speak for myself i
drink responsibly despite the
stereotyping
about american politics because she's
canadian and doesn't have to face the
consequences i also want to mention
leaving the thing about her
mention we have 51 minutes until it
starts of course one of the options on
our bingo card is starts late so might
be longer than 51 minutes
he's going to be late we're all drinking
for that one i want to point out that
canada is america north america north
america north shout out to americo
vespucci the italian uh discoverer
yeah i don't know so here's what mine
says i have one that says if joe biden
uses newspeak like latinx i have to
drink latinx yeah scared that's a good
are they all the same are they all
different they're supposed to be like
some variation
there's inappropriate contact on mine
that'll happen
we're excited to use his fake words
racist by accident racist by accident
that's my favorite might as well circle
that one yeah just get out of the way
whispers he'll do that he'll go get
vaccinated i don't have a dog in the
fight but if he does walks wrong way i'm
going to be really happy
how many of these should we read out i
mean i don't want to spoil the jokes but
it's also possible every one of these
things yeah so it's going to be funny
too because we're gonna have to judge if
something was like adequately racist you
know what i mean like accident racist or
accidentally well no no no i mean like
if if he says something and we're like
okay that sounds like it kind of was
racist
you know but what if it's what if it's
tim we're going to give him the benefit
of the doubt he would give us if we said
something so essentially construed is
racist yes
so who what is the winner you'll get
inappropriate content
we're going to drink right when it
starts
i have to win at that point yeah you do
okay wait wait wait uh only democrats
clap
that's gonna keep happening yeah it's
going to happen multiple times but we'll
see him you actually don't know what if
he doesn't do any of these things it's
his best speech ever he goes out he's
like my fellow americans
i say on the dawn of a potential third
world war we must come together as a
nation and we're like what's going on
forgets what
[Laughter]
so he's gonna be like
my fellow americans we stand on the
precipice of a great world war world war
three between
uh
ukrainians between
[Laughter]
i actually suggested when we're making
this that we include saying corn pop
but i was like we should have like wager
bingo spots where it's leveraged so like
because the likelihood of him saying
corn pop is like point zero one percent
you gotta like chug your whole beer if
he says it snap yeah it's like okay corn
pop or malarkey we have to chug our
beers malarkey if you've been saying hey
guys the words
i'm writing this down
i'm really enjoying this because um like
the story we have to talk about right
now is that belarus
here i'm using the daily beasts i love
it they say belarus issues dire world
war three warning as it gets ready to
send troops to ukraine they've also
approved russia staging nuclear weapons
in belarusian borders ukraine has said
they've already invaded you've got a
ukrainian journalist in poland telling
boris uh from the uk pm
that world war iii has already started
and nato needs to intervene with a
no-fly zone and i'm sitting here like
this is like the most serious news i
think i've ever experienced in my adult
life i don't know if any i guess you
know look with um iraq afghanistan and
those wars
i wasn't really worried they were going
to nuke us or send you know waved or
wave of their own men you know what
though they said they could because that
was the whole thing they talked about
wmds and they were saying we have to go
over there because we don't find out
it's too late after they already knew us
and then it's funny because even though
they made up all these lies about how
saddam was close to getting a nuke and
how that was a wmd they said well we
weren't lying about weapons of mass
destruction because there were chemical
weapons there that can be considered
wmds
yeah i think there were i mean yeah yes
but that's different from nuclear
weaponry obviously when they were saying
weapons of mass destruction in the minds
of the public that construed an image of
nuclear weapons and then they said oh of
course there were wmds it was like
chemicals so so let's let's just put
layer upon layer on this one so we got
all this stuff happening and i'm like
okay it's kind of freaking out you know
kind of freaking me out but uh you know
we can all laugh here and make make fun
of joe biden and you know if if there's
one thing joe biden's done is he's made
us all laugh that's true he's probably
sorry well that's the thing about joe
biden i said this as soon as you got
elected finally a president who can't
disappoint me yeah there's no possible
way
and uh you know he he makes us laugh
every now and again it's true it's true
and so yeah horrible situation going on
over there we don't want to make light
of it it is frightening in many ways but
one of the purposes of comedy is to be
able to
get people to to um
keep their spirits up through difficult
times so there's another thing that
happened um on tv
the president of belarus uh lukashenko
was pointing to a map that showed
uh what appeared to be the russian
military plan
from uh russia and belarus into ukraine
but there were several attack points
drawn on the map that haven't happened
and so of course a lot many in the media
are saying haven't happened yet as if
it's you know the actual plan that
russia has
and now if that's true and i don't know
why it would be i don't know what that
map is it shows i think four accurate
attack factors that have already
occurred as well as several others that
make people think they might occur
because some are like right like right
after kharkiv there's like another
attack movement
is the implication that there's like
some planning or that's just their guess
the impli the implication well i don't
know why the president of belarus put
the map up like he was explaining like
here's what's happening but the
implication is that what they're saying
belarus an ally of russia they know what
the military plan is
and they've effectively shown the next
move will be to move into odessa and
then into moldova or they could be fake
plans yeah
it could just be but but if it is it
could be fake the scary thing is and
maybe this is just
him trying to freak people out trying to
fog of war you know confuse people false
orders
or like psychological manipulation this
implies russia will invade another
country notably the the disputed
territory is transnistria which has
already got russian troops there which
could be then used by russia as a
staging ground to bypass ukrainian
defenses and then move through the
southwest of the country it might still
remain just a ukraine thing but
you've also got kaliningrad there's a
lot of crazy stuff here man so um i
don't know world war iii at a glance the
red lines on this i mean this is like a
daily mail article i'm looking at i
didn't i haven't investigated the map
but maybe those are red lines indicating
where infiltration has already taken
place like where there's russian special
forces awaiting action because they said
moldova's already infiltrated crimea was
already infiltrated obviously and it
looks like a lot of parts of ukraine had
already been infiltrated on the map
maybe
i don't know but i would i would imagine
more than it's a battle map or a fake
battle map
yeah i mean to what tim was saying about
the fact that there are certain places
where they're saying they're going to
attack they could they couldn't i have
absolutely no idea i will say this we
should um we should
believe the media about as much as we
would if they were reporting on anything
else oh yeah yeah i tweeted i love this
whenever anything in the media happens
i'm just going to call them the people
who believe jesse smelled no exactly
exactly you know during covet i was like
the people who believe justice malette
are lecturing me on kovid and then i
tweeted and i got like three thousand
retweets then i tweeted the other day or
maybe this morning the people who
believe jesse smilet are lecturing me on
ukraine and it got like thousands of
retweets it's true fantastic no it's
true yeah and you're from mega country
dude i want to clear this up i saw you
on twitter trending that was awesome and
then i found out because you said i
don't like appeals to emotion is that
what it is appeal to emotion it's a type
of argument an ad hominem or an ad
emotional attack or something it's it's
an it's an appeal to emotion so they're
you know yes i was training for that and
they're trying first they got it wrong
um there's a video clip of zelensky
talking about you know civilians dying
but the translator is crying as he's
saying it
that's what i'm talking about so
propaganda so that was the news story
that went viral appeal to emotion what
you were talking about is a logical
fallacy characterized by the
manipulation of the recipient's emotions
correct in order to win an argument so i
understand your point the idea here is
that they're playing this video clip of
zelinski being like children are dying
and and civilians are under attack and
the translator is going
we must fight
for our children's freedom
and i'm just like
that person should be fired no no joke
that person should be should be uh maybe
not five that's a little harsh they
should leave well if if i were the boss
and we were doing a live translation
broadcast i go up to the guide and i'd
be like let's let's get you in here man
get your cup of coffee why don't you
have a seat breathe a little bit and
we'll get someone in here who can hand
you know i think no disrespect this is
the translator crying because i've seen
this so it's funny the trending you're
talking about i actually i follow a
bunch of lefty accounts to get their
side of things and i saw your tweet
screenshotted like four times before i
even saw your original tweet and um this
comment was from a bigger account saying
the thing that really pisses me off
about this war is the leader of the
country being invaded saying he thinks
it's bad that kids are being killed like
i'm so that's what they're suggesting
you're saying right well i don't care
about those people like it's it's like
if you i mean so they didn't watch the
video in the original of course
and they did it on purpose because if
you actually watched the video you'd be
like oh
it's not the president who's talking
because i don't understand ukrainian
it's some it's an eu translator who's
crying as he's talking and so my point
is
what they're trying to do with a lot of
this propaganda is appeal to your
emotions to get you to join a war effort
yes of course the the zealot pro-war
lunatics are going to come after me for
whatever i tweet i tweeted a very
obvious joke i mean of anyone who's
smart enough to understand it's zylenski
doing the the red salute i actually want
to do it but the communist salute and um
i said you know i said whoa the
president of ukraine just did the
communist salute or maybe he's
supporting black lives matter i can't
tell if he's supporting communism or
critical race theory like
and there so ethan klein of h3 was like
he's actually trying to claim that
ukraine's president is a communist
because he's using the international
sign of resistance or whatever and my
response was uh you're gonna love this
it was it was a great response i said
thanks ethan big fan
i don't care whatever man so yeah tim is
actually a big fan can you believe this
i know could you believe it you know
well here's what i'm thinking somebody
some some people actually responded to
the left accurately on this and they
were like
someone said it's a joke chill and
they're like well i can't tell it's a
joke and so he needs to blah blah blah
and then someone responded
tim believes that taking twitter
seriously and engaging with people is
ineffective and it's healthier just to
tweet it all i could like treat it all
like it's unserious and a big joke and
that's
fairly accurate it might as well be
because even the serious accounts that
are verified the mainstream media
they're just being serious but spreading
misinformation as well so if you take it
seriously you're almost in a worse
position if you take everything you read
on twitter seriously i've said this
before twitter is a terrible website
when you are having um a good day on
twitter it's because you said something
mean to someone and everyone thinks
you're funny when you're having a bad
day on twitter it's because someone said
something mean to you and everyone
thinks that's funny that's what the
website is for i'm just being cruel i
tweeted absolutely deter sarcasm speak
with honesty because emotions people are
bouncing on a needle's point about to
lose it i tweeted that out because i
keep seeing a lot of people i follow on
twitter are joking right now like being
sarcastic and it's not translating in
text yeah it's just confusing people did
you see the girl that did the poem to
putin oh or she was like if i were
putin's mother i would have helped if i
was your mother i would have held you
tight putin you would have had mommy
monkeys it would have been all okay
[Laughter]
that is not family she got absolutely
like obliterated i kind of feel bad is
she serious because she was being
serious but she was trying to be like
artistic and like she she actually is
like a good soul you can tell she's
trying to be nice but it it doesn't work
on twitter this website is for
emotionally destroying that is like the
ultimate i can fix him
yeah it really is i can fix booting
it is
you know what you know you know what
they don't like about me on twitter is
that you're right it's for emotionally
destroying people and
they have no power over me so someone
someone tweeted at me an image if it's
the npc meme but it's me wearing the
baseball tee and the beanie that was
hilarious and so i posted on instagram
because i think it's funny and there's a
bunch of funny ones there's one where my
it's me but my head's a blimp it's got a
beanie on so good so it's like i'm in a
hot air it's a hottie i'm in a hot air
balloon of my own brain
with a basket that i'm standing in and a
little beanie on top and i'm like i
think that's great
my favorite though was uh the the
patriots.win formerly the donald have
been making all of these really funny um
anti like these memes about the
propaganda coming out of ukraine
so like the ghost of
kiev and like so they've been like the
cuck of kiev is mitt romney or whatever
but they made one where it was like this
is the fence sitter of kiev
his sitting on the fence has held the
russian forces at bay and they
superimposed my face over some ukrainian
soldier
and then in the comments they were like
i hope tim sees this because he's going
to laugh and then i put you know i can't
confirm true well
i'm like dude
that's that's the thing like i'll go on
twitter and they can say literally
anything and
that you when when ethan kline tweeted
at me like what am i supposed to do what
does any regular person supposed to do
when someone's just making up stuff or
insulting you or supposed to you're
supposed to drop your jaw and stutter
and not have respect
because you just got out sometimes to
happen sometimes people retweet the the
one that they have issues with and then
explain why it's wrong i i didn't like
that because they just like then you're
retweeting the person you disagree with
i'd rather just ignore it i just
retweeted it
there's um that great anecdote where
it's like if if you get in the ring with
them someone is just trying to pull you
down it's like you're getting in the mud
pit with the pigs and you just get dirty
and the pigs just get happy whereas
you're kind of standing on the sideline
have fun pigs i like you yeah enjoy you
you know i don't know what i'm gonna do
next time i'm gonna you know you know
what i should have tweeted i'm thinking
like you i obviously can't respond with
like here's my actual argument blah blah
blah like that's stupid nobody cares so
i just said thanks to ethan big fan
because like i'm trending now thanks to
him you know what i mean there you go i
think next time i'll just put i'm sorry
that's it
i publicly followed i publicly
apologized me on your podcast i wouldn't
say that no but like the point of the
apology is they would be like is he
being serious do you think you could
hashtag i'm sorry to trend yeah let's
see if you can pull it off
i apologize
for for for being wrong do a public
apology and then like plug raid shadow
legends or something like that
halfway through your public apology they
reached out to sponsor me and then they
like looked at my channel and they were
like oh we made a mistake
that was an accidental email
there's a hilarious meme of putin uh
talk it was obviously a fake translation
of his uh him speaking in russian and it
just was a long troll into saying that
his invasion of ukraine was just a
hilarious advertisement for rage shadows
oh i saw that
it's him talking and there's like text
and he's like i did all of this to
generate massive global attention for a
very important issue rage shadow legends
available now
we did it we had a joke james i don't
know if if if i i don't know if you ever
see this the the the fouchy youtube one
should we mention no no we can't say
that one no that that's awesome yeah
yeah yeah that was a good one or the one
where he's just trying to follow up with
zelensky on his taxes or something
what what happened well so so tim and i
wrote some we did some funny improv some
funny jokes which is going to be for for
uh my supporters behind the paywall
because it would absolutely get us
deleted from youtube forever
all right guys well you can't do that to
people i want to say i can
i absolutely can i gotta pull up this
this uh this
is amazing ladies and gentlemen i have a
very important fact check for you from
politifact um you see uh maria bartoromo
yeah
how could she she said we have doubled
our oil imports from russia in the last
year what does she think she is
clarifies the us did not double oil
imports from russia in the last year
okay what actually happened was
according to politifact the us did
double the amount of crude oil import
from russia last year so they says both
of those things in the same article they
meant mostly false like mostly peaceful
yeah wait wait i i actually i have to
interrupt the i hate to do this but the
crude oil is one type of various types
of oil imported to the us so i so we we
doubled one type not oil in general oh
but she didn't even maria barona didn't
even yeah no it was it was terribly
written terribly wrong
in parentheses so when uh
when maria was talking uh she's talking
with jesse waters i believe she said we
have doubled our imports from russia in
the last year referring to generally
just oil well that's supposed to be in
brackets not in parentheses it is the
point is
her statement is correct she wasn't
speaking very specifically and
absolutely she was saying here's one
particular issue if she was referring to
crude oil it's absolutely correct but of
course the fact check just assumes that
it's going to be completely yeah why
didn't they put crude
when they add look at this they added
the word oil to her quote she did not
say that wrong and here's the thing too
with the mostly false you could put
like that can go either way you can say
mostly false or mostly true it could be
yeah mostly true
that's what i'm saying they're using it
the way that he's mostly peaceful mostly
is a magic word maybe means the same
thing as maybe not it's it has the exact
same meaning it's so blatant to the
mainstream media and these fact checkers
are trying to trying to pretend like and
they did this in canada as well
you know when you buy oil from the
russian regime you're directly
sponsoring their war effort you're
paying for it and these mainstream media
journalists are just so desperate to
make it to gaslight canadians and
americans into thinking that that's not
yeah exactly
completely intentional
um it's interesting that that's not
what's hap that's not what is happening
because they want to draw your attention
away from keystone xl this this like
obvious policy decision that should be
reversed um it never should have been
canceled in the first place but uh the
mainstream media is they're just
breathless and they're in their support
for the russian regime was the canadian
uh was the support for keystone really
really powerful and then the americans
wanted it shut down or did everybody oh
it depends where you were
in like alberta it was super like super
supportive uh western canada generally
uh was hugely supportive of this right
and then
sorry ian we don't ask the canadians
about canada we asked about america oh
yeah i want the outside perspective
right but no continue please so i mean
lots of canadians wanted it there was no
there was no canadians really saying we
shouldn't do it the the
opposition was american leftists and and
frankly foreign funded activists in
canada because you americans absolutely
fun eco radicals but you should mention
we fund you guys too what are you
talking about you should mention
those radical activists held and like
blocked the pipeline for years and they
had to go through the legal court
process to get them arrested get them
taken away and so people talk about the
ottawa like they were there for two
weeks and it was hurting industry
the people blocking the pipeline have
been there for years and they still went
through total double standard when it
comes to blocking infrastructure no no
no come on be honest guys they weren't
honking horns
no they just killed like what did they
kill an rcmp officer no they actually
they this so this was a different
pipeline this was a big one heading
westbound up in northern bc but as the
truckers were
occupying as some people are saying or
but basically protesting in ottawa and
honking a lot there was an actual
terrorist attack in northern british
columbia for this northern gateway for
for this coastal gasline pipeline that
was going to carry liquefied natural gas
they actually
a bunch of camouflaged men
radical indigenous eco-radicals funded
by americans came into this site and
trashed a bunch of vehicles burnt things
with hatchets tomahawks all the whole
shebang billions of dollars in damage
yeah but you can't compare that to
honking yeah
i mean people's ears were hurting yeah
did you have you seen that article about
the phantom honking
what is it
tell me about it
apparently it's people hearing honking
after there's no honking maybe the
trucks are just gone but people are like
actually honking experience because
that's what cars do and they're like i
can still hear them
from the convoy
you know but you need to understand is
these people probably do have ptsd and
here's the issue
if you are a soft
pink mask
of cookie dough
that has never experienced any hardship
and you grow up that way and your entire
world view is based on living in a
padded room of pastel colors and
sing-alongs and harry potter and star
wars
then when someone walks in and yells at
you it's traumatizing to you
you are you have so i'm half kidding but
for these people who have been you know
pampered urban uh you know elite types
or not even sorry elite types but you
know they're they're they lack any kind
of hard experience
hearing those constant honkings is
stressing them out because it does two
things the first is the
physical agitation of constantly hearing
the honking i don't mean any kind of
violence but like that its presence is
physical to them but also the
psychological impact of them
being potentially wrong these are people
who are desperate to fit in and all of a
sudden there's a big popular movement
outside and they're all cheering and
dancing and screaming and you're not a
part of it
they seek refuge online where people are
like don't worry we hate them too you're
one of us and that makes them feel
better in their anger
so yeah some kind of trauma i suppose
and now uh yeah people are probably
talking their horns and as soon as they
do someone probably screams and freaks
out it's happening every weekend i don't
think people realize like even when i
was going to the airport in canada there
were still people on every bridge
everyone has canadian flights on their
car cars i never realized how many
people thought like me until yesterday i
didn't realize that many canadian
flights were so it looked like fourth of
july in canada the canadian flag has
become like the american flag yeah yeah
and liberal symbol of patriotism yeah
you guys have a you guys have a maple
leaf on your flag
to make fun of our maple i was gonna say
it's very cute i'm into it adorable
frankly i wanted the turkey
[Laughter]
canadian red ensign beautiful flag but
then the liberals they took you know
everything that was good about our
country yeah and oh wow that was cool
yeah interesting this is better than
that right at least that was our flag
world war one world war ii well the
crest was a little bit different it
changed over time but that was the most
recent version of the flag they're the
leaves now there's this one dude how
long till they put a maple leaf on this
is the first one i like the maple leaf
but i want more colors that was the one
they fought in under world war two i
think world war one so rad look at this
amazing canadian flag
you know how much more respect canada
would get if that was still your fault
all the people that say canada's not
part of the british empire uh check
please what can you guys tell me do a
little bit wait wait wait wait wait wait
let's not make it let's leave them alone
hold on hold on a minute hold on a
minute this is legit you said this is it
yeah i mean this is from wikimedia look
at this not only does it have the union
jack which is the united kingdom it's
got a crown it's got a a bison i believe
a fish but also a wreath of maple leafs
yeah i've heard this three i've heard
the three leaves this could be i could
be making this up but i heard that it
represents like the three different
populations in canada like the english
the french and the indigenous cool nice
i like it it does so in within that
little crest the three there there's two
of them so these are a lot of local like
communities
these were all like the different parts
of canada
like new brunswick and all that like the
thistles
so what is this single hold on has
generally changed when when did they
decide to ruin your country wasn't that
long ago yeah well yeah it was actually
quite recent like i think maybe in the
60s that was like my thought too but i
don't want to spread it more thank you i
said an rcmp officer was killed by those
protesters i just want to clarify they
just like
like
i don't think we should be so violent
you know let's change that plague
this is the frustrating this might be
like esoteric canadian politics but i'm
from i'm from the west uh from alberta
i'm an albertan separatist actually and
um
it's frustrating about that flag because
that's the maple leaf and there's no
maple trees west of like manitoba right
so the cities like eastern elitists uh
came and said yeah let's put the maple
leaf on the flag because that represents
canada but really that's just the
laurentian understanding of canada these
like eastern like trudeau
all of these eastern liberals have
decided to sort of
usurp the understanding of canada and
replaced the union jack and all of those
that beautiful crest that obviously
represented every part of canada and
then said now we just want to use a leaf
from a tree that only exists in quebec
you know i actually really like that
this happened to the flag because it's
such a simple and concise way to explain
how they made everything dumb and
horrible in canada you're like okay well
in this time frame they took this out
they removed all the people who live in
this part of the country and now it's
just like this elitist oversimplified
kind of like a globalist flag they did
the uh modern corporate art yeah
oh my gosh it's a modern logo i mean how
long before that happens in america like
these 13 stripes represent 13 slave
colonies we need to change this flag all
together just the star what would it be
like the mcdonald's golden arches yeah
something like that it's something
corporate yeah yeah it's 100 no it would
just be like the star by itself maybe or
i don't know
the canadian flag if you add more color
i'd be down like a psychedelic flag
would be neat but i don't know
what if we added stripes horizontal
stripes and then we did like a rainbow
oh you know they've done that oh okay
that actual flag has flown on parliament
hill like
what do you guys think about symbology
in general and flags i mean because i
personally like burn the flag i don't
care yeah have you ever watched boondock
saints i think once yeah does anybody
here watch boondock saints it was a cool
cartoon willem
dafoe when the cop is like symbology and
he goes symbolism
okay i'm i'm making up words because i'm
english that's what joe biden is going
to do joe biden
yeah symbology is a thing i don't know a
symbol but that's like the study of
symbols exactly the study of symbols
right in general do you do you think
that it's cause i find it's kind of like
cult worship like everyone worship me
because i have the icon now and if you
i'm the one that has the the
badge like i don't burn the flag if you
want to practice i disagree
it is in the eye of the beholder right
like it means to people something
obviously it means something different
to everyone who sees it when i see that
canadian
we call the maple rag in alberta it you
know it it brings on ideas of of eastern
oppression uh just like you guys
probably would have felt americans back
in
1770 whatever the heck it was when you
guys threw the tea in the harbor and
decided to become a bunch of trolls
traders okay
the big cities of canada are ripping you
guys off yeah oh absolutely because like
they tell us we can't have pipelines
they tell us we have to shut down our
oil and gas industry um they force weird
taxes on us that
make us pay for social programs in
quebec which are ridiculous when it
comes to managing their budget um so we
fund their social programs they go
deeper into debt and we have to pay for
it yeah so so before we move on i just
have to ask are you guys kind of feeling
the national divorce thing in canada as
well because it's been going on for a
while yeah trudeau and and biden as well
it's mirroring on both sides of the
border they're both saying that oh you
know we're the most united we've ever
been oh are we and that's obviously not
the case in canada and i think i assume
the united states
spot on the bingo i would i mean biden
trudeau are probably more united than
ever before but the people of their
country are not the actual united under
uh klaus schwab yes exactly i love that
guy yeah he's great so come on man we
had uh one guest was saying that canada
has actually had very serious points of
you know near
near i don't know about total collapse
but like breaking apart in like the 80s
and the 90s yeah quebec it was like 49
to 51 wasn't it for secession
it was a couple thousand votes it was
very very tight yeah i would have made
them an independent nation yeah and they
they are very culturally different like
if you go to quebec literally it feels
like europe to some extent
they're like france's mentally
challenged cousins but is it is it is it
montreal in quebec does it speak english
so montreal is fairly like half and half
though like half kind of french kind of
english but like quebec city is isn't it
like all french yeah yeah they have such
but they're also very very prominent
they are that's the thing that's i'm
having so much trouble because when you
go to quebec and you don't speak french
they're like horrible to you but then
all of the cool politicians are coming
from there now because they've got that
sense of nationalism like pierre
polaviere maxine bernier
actually from calgary just like ted cruz
i just said
so i'm just discriminating if they were
too if like um quebec did secede would
they be then with the british because
like i'm i'm a little it's fuzzy about
the connection between canada and the
british empire you know it's part of the
common i believe it's part of the
commonwealth yeah we were part of the
community and then so if quebec was to
secede would it still be part of the
commonwealth no they do not want to be a
part of the congress and then with the
british like just sending the royal you
know the canadian mountain police or
whatever and come in
the king says there was a supreme court
ruling that like the clarity act is what
it was called and it allowed for
any place in canada basically to
separate if there was a clear margin and
a clear question when it came to
secession and
it's a big question whether or not
quebec would have met that if they were
over 50 or not but at the end of the day
they weren't they were 49 so nobody
really knows but if they were you know
say 60 of them voted to leave there's a
supreme court ruling that says we can do
it for 49 oh they needed 60 well they
needed more than 50 of these and they
got 49. yeah
wow what a weird strange dark
coincidence let's talk about uh what's
going on here in the us before we do i
want to give a shout out to uh because
it's a special episode timcast.com if
you guys haven't already this is we got
a team of journalists they write they
report on news every single day we we
fact check we have a bunch of shows if
you want to support our work go to
timcast.com become a member i don't
think we're gonna have a member segment
tonight because we're probably gonna do
this show long because i imagine the
state of the union will be a bit of time
but if you want to keep the show going
you want to support our journalists
signing up at timcast.com you'll also
get access to our whole members only
library we have a ton of awesome members
only shows including one with lauren
last night yeah talked about flat earth
for some reason so good i was atlantis
landing
it was fun it was fun so you can
definitely support us there and i just
want to mention too because for those
that are just tuning in we do have these
bingo cards and we're about 20 minutes
out from the schedule time for biden
state of the union allegedly in which
allegedly in which we will be enjoying
these fine beers from old 690 brewing
company and whenever biden engages in
one of these behaviors
we will uh be taking a drink and marking
it off so i've got like only democrats
clap mentions january 6th uses a fake
word fake tough guy starts late could
you i'm just pointing i was just
thinking this like what if he starts by
literally hitting every single one of
these in one paragraph he just died
where where he like he's late
he comes out and he goes i undercover
man no he comes out and he's like i'm
sick of these bullies
people like putin donald trump will
exponentially get worse
especially with january 6th and then
only democrats collapse yeah
this is after he tripped up the stage
gets pulled off early we're going to
stop russia we're trooning that shot
under pressure does he read this off a
teleprompter yeah his teleprompter is
really bad at spelling and so he just
like writes random things
well that should have been one squinting
at the top oh squinting would be a good
one and people need to realize that no
one where were you no that's not true
you didn't first of all you absolutely
you ignored me you got all that eye
working i'm sorry what's going on or
something it looks like it's perma
squint
yeah i don't know but you can tell
i think a lot of people misunderstand
too when biden will stop talking or
stutter or stammer it's not always
because he's losing his mind it's
because the prompter isn't moving fast
enough yeah so you'll notice this wait
well that tucker carlson yeah one of the
things you'll notice he does is he adds
he has his special thing where he adds
words actually
and
or you know or he does a thing where he
was like and some might accuse me of
rooting for russia which i am oh you
know like he adds that last bit because
it allows the prompter to move a little
bit i'm assuming that maybe that's just
who he is but there are some points
where i'm like he did that because i've
read from prompters before i've done you
know news reports and it's like you're
waiting for it to catch up and if you
have that freedom you can do it a lot of
places will have like the pedal though
yeah you should have actually i i did
the news in australia a bit and the
pedal stopped working once there's no
other like worse fear
in the world than being live on the news
and i'd tell them to pedal
doing i can't even i think someone else
beside me saw that mine wasn't working
and just like saved my ass oh thank you
is it like you push it forward and it
speeds up and you push it back and it
goes backwards yeah and like you know
you got to be like driving a standard
manual you need a license for it yeah i
mean biden could not handle a pedal no
no i mean you could barely stand up so
here's what we're going to do um
instead of doing the normal super chats
because i think we're going to we'll
just read super chats while the state of
union is going to do that so we'll of
course all be laughing and joking and
drinking and marking off our bingo cards
but then we as well will read your super
chats as like often as we can
within reason you know funny jokes and
comments you might have to add to things
or fact checks and then we'll be fact
checking as much as we can as well
i think most people here considering the
the eclectic bunch we are of politicos
and people who read the news i think
it's gonna be very easy to fact check a
lot of what biden says he'll say
something and then immediately sheamus
or you know kiana will just be like oh
that was x y and z he's quite the expert
yes yes well let's do this we still have
about 17 minutes i do believe they'll be
late but let's talk about what's
happening with this people's convoy
we have the story from the daily mail
the people's convoy reaches illinois as
it makes its way to washington dc for
trucker anti-mandate protest capital is
on high alert ahead of state of the
union address i will also add over at
timcast.com we have a reporter elad
who's currently tracking with the convoy
right now he's going alongside and
interviewing them those videos are up be
a member if you want but they're free we
get that news reporting to you guys but
this is interesting because this is not
the freedom convoy this is the people's
convoy it's different yeah yeah so the
freedom convoy i don't yeah i don't know
if the freedom convoy for the us like
didn't make it or what's going on with
it i
i don't i thought it was just one whole
time i was surprised it was like 12
actually i just know there's a convoy
and it's got about 250 people and it's
going to be arriving in dc on the 5th
and they're like i mentioned maybe it's
just for the state of the union but they
have put up all the barricades around
the white white house sorry the capitol
two different white buildings
but yeah they put up all the barricades
they're pretty worried about this do you
guys think it's gonna
get like trudeau level where it's just
gonna be honking in the capital no no
what do you think is going to happen
the the dc police
are very very good at dealing with
protests
and i imagine for one the truckers
probably i think it's a good chance they
won't even be able to make it into the
city um
as they start arriving there's going to
be cops at key entry points and they're
going to you know fan the trucks in the
other direction so they i don't i don't
think the trucks will get into the heart
of dc like like what happened with
ottawa boy did they really screw that up
the simple logistics could have
prevented the protesters from succeeding
but man canada trudeau
and the provincial government didn't
seem to know how to handle that but i
think
the u.s is going to be able to more
importantly however i think the bigger
risk is
they'll let them come in
and then you'll get some narrative about
insurrection again yeah yeah yeah
they'll they'll manipulate it they'll
use it and they'll say oh let them come
and there's already been reports people
are saying that there have been feds who
are trying to infiltrate or incite
people and they're like no no no so i'm
hearing that
many of the people are saying they don't
want to go to the core of dc
for that reason they want to stay
slightly outside so they can make their
point
you know be like protest and you know
obstruct enough without actually
getting anywhere near close to these
buildings well isn't it interesting that
this had the effect of making people
feel too afraid to protest near the
actual center of political power
yeah but you might just have ray epps on
the
ray wants to come on the show and uh
talk about stuff
maybe i don't know about that fbi no fbi
what's up maybe i think we have to i
think he has to have to do a sit-down
interview answering a ton of questions
before we would just have you know
did you just buy a lie detector yes
did we just buy one for i would say
donuts or something with the fridge you
needed a live stream oh yeah somebody
somebody we i bought a bunch of these
donuts and they come with you have to
like build them yourself yeah is that
you no did someone eat just the doughnut
ian's got friends they just ate the
frost face worse that was amazing
someone someone stole blasphemy seven
icings
from our donuts we have other sugars in
the house why would they be i want
people but they didn't eat the donut
so somebody like took the icing and just
drank it i would be so i think it might
have been joe biden that's probably
who's the sugar joe biden's sneaking in
at three in the morning and he's like
come on
but he's whispering to himself come on
man as he's open up the dump come on
so anyway yes oh man the plan is we're
everyone's denying it so we got a lie
detector we i think we're ordering one
or something like like a fake you know
thrift store like detector something
like that a used polygraph can you get
like a top top cia quality lie detector
just
just
just
just
just
just
just
just just
just
just
just
just
just
just
just just pick it up it's all bsn don't worry
yeah they don't really work because it's
if you think you're lying it'll go if
you're if you have agitation but if
you're lying in your column it won't
know that's not why they don't use the
record right it's looking to see if
you're stressed by the question
yeah so if you're nervous the whole time
it's fine but if they see stress when
you answer a question they're gonna
think by the way that's how the neural
net and metaverse is gonna be tracking
you if they sense your emotions oh dude
they can read everything you gotta have
to have just a solidly clear mind when
you're in there i've already joined the
um what are we calling it are we calling
it the continuum or the singularity the
singularity oh gosh why the singularity
don't like that so i got a whoopee the
boss i got you've joined hilarity what
is it yeah luke luke convinced me he
said one of us when i was like no he
looked up and then he pinned me down and
he put the whoop on my wrist
you were right it tracks your health and
it shows you like your strain and your
recovery it shows you your heart rate
your skin temperature your you know
resting heart rate my resting heart rate
48. beautiful it's pretty good yeah
actually so uh i went to the doctor for
a physical because i was feeling sick
turns out i was dehydrated and they
hooked me up to the heart rate thing and
i looked at it and it was in the low 50s
and then it dropped down to like 45 and
it started going
like low heart rate warning yeah and i
was just like what do i do like yeah i'm
fine and the nurse came in and she was
like are you very active and i was like
yeah and she's like okay and then she's
like ignored it yeah when i worked in a
cardiology unit we had a biker guy who
was ended up in one of the icu units i'm
assuming he got hit by a car or
something and his alarm was constantly
buzzing we had to set it to a lower rate
because he was like hanging out in the
40s 38 39 they thought he had a heart
block and i was like no it's just really
freaking fit it turns out wow good
hearts huh yeah yeah my goal is to get
my resting heart rate to one not doesn't
work just for a moment no i don't think
so
the lowest i've ever seen it was uh for
me was 42. that's real low yep and you
know uh
like i exercise a lot but anyway the
whoop is it you know somebody said cause
luke was wearing one on the show
and somebody said that it like sends all
your data to the corporations or
whatever and it's like a bunch of lasers
and it's tracking everything and i'm
like i don't know it's telling me you
know i have it all in here luke
you know what the interesting thing is
uh when i wake up it tells me like
here's your recovery from your sleep and
it's always telling me that i need to
sleep for like 12 hours but i sleep for
like six and i'm like i can't sleep
anymore i'm working you know but it
shows my my recovery rate the funny
thing is i don't need it to tell me if i
feel good when i wake up because i feel
good or i feel bad that's weird that
it's telling you you feel good well no
it's just things that it says like 78
recovery or something it's a green and
it's like good job but when i wake up
i'm like i feel great because
technically it's proprietary and if a
crazy person gets the corporation they
can be like yeah let's tell him he feels
like trash let's tell him his resting
heart rate's way lower than it is like
screw it no but uh when i was dehydrated
i had two nights where my recovery was
extremely low and the issue was i was
drinking regular water not getting
electrolytes so i wasn't retaining and
that was the problem interesting so i i
i thought like i drank a bunch of water
and then i was told by the doctor
gatorade and so i drank a bunch of
gatorade and then all of a sudden i was
like oh man your heart needs
electrolytes i did not realize because
i'm always drinking you know water or uh
like like lemon juice in water and stuff
like that so electrolytes is making that
black water is really good we got this
new mineral black water it's a little
sweet and it's dark dark dark brown with
minerals 72 different added minerals
pretty cool looks great a gimmick
yeah i wonder if it is yeah you know
what you guys have two downstairs you
have air in a tank air in a cage i don't
have air in a can i did
it's not air it was just air it's not
air what is it
oxygen pure oxygen you know what it's
not the same thing
so you know this is you know i'm a smart
ass right so we were at we were at
youtube
we were at dick's sporting goods and uh
we were we were getting a new treadmill
and we're getting a new workout thing
because we like we genuinely here want
everyone to work out and i even said
like i'll get like a trainer to get
everybody to exercise because we want
people to eat right and be better and be
strong
and um
the guy they have these oxygen canisters
at the uh
at the counter when we're checking out
and i said you know inhaling pure oxygen
is bad for you it's 95
and the guy goes no it's just air and i
was like
nope actually it's not it's oxygen and
he goes and what do you breathe and i
was like we breathe air which is a
combination of mostly nitrogen carbon
dioxide oxygen trace
gases like methane and then he was like
oh and i'm like people really think that
we breathe oxygen that's like all air is
78 nitrogen yeah i'm pretty sure it
wouldn't let the atmosphere ignite if it
was if it was like
above like certain percentage of oxygen
or something like that oh interesting
yeah that's probably why it burned off
that's probably what happened yeah i
don't know i'm not going to pretend to
know all about that all i know is that i
learned when i was like 5th grade that's
mostly nitrogen or
yeah is a fascinating chemical
of
whatever
is it so it's air it's it's it's i'm
sorry it's gas it's not air when you say
what's in there it's gas it's fluid it's
not necessarily air
oh hey the air i guess all right so the
air come on
they officially started the state of the
union stream it started early
no no no no no no i can't believe
biden's trying to compete with the
stream has begun
but right now it's just a picture of joe
biden he needs like a band to play it
like why do you think or something why
do you think they disabled the comments
like i thought there was like a first
amendment here in the united states 81
million why do you think they hit the
dislike counter that's crazy do you hey
install the install the the dislike
button uh app
on chrome let's check that right now it
doesn't happen on my laptop it doesn't
actually show you the real dislike it
guesses
based on what did you get it guess it's
based on uh
you can read you can read they say the
first wave was based on the data they
already had on dislikes and the next is
based on metrics that correlate with
dislikes or something i feel like we
could test this theory by looking in the
back end and then getting someone else
to use it on our video you know
i could see you could track the amount
of total clicks then the amount of total
likes and then subtract it and get the
amount of total dislikes i will say it's
like button anymore i've noticed that
since they've gotten rid of the dislike
button i get way less dislikes yeah i
was going to say people don't feel as
driven to do so because it's not going
to be a bad look for you in the
beginning
remember when they used to rate five
stars one through five stars i would
give someone five stars or i wouldn't
vote i hated trashing people like uber
drivers yeah you gotta give them five
stars here that's right yeah just don't
worry otherwise they get fired they know
unless they're speeding and then let
everyone know you're not safe um so so
they disabled the comments and i just
want to say so we have right here the
president's state of union address from
the white house official youtube which
of course is public domain of course and
uh chet is disabled i just uh i would
love to see that nightmare of a
hellscape
if they allowed it and they should and i
actually think um
i think
they should be obligated to have that
because
is what's interesting it says they've
disabled it
that means the government has barred the
public from something that should be
there like didn't they try to sue donald
trump for blocking people on twitter yes
yeah now the argument they could say is
by having no chat for anyone it's not
very equal you know it but i would argue
this
they've disabled chat for the public and
chet is a basic core function of a live
stream therefore my argument is
the government is suppressing the right
of the people to speak at a public event
and associate especially when the
internet has become the new public
sphere you look at with lockdown like
you forced us in our homes and now we're
all online and now we've got the
metaverse and now this is the new public
sphere where we all talk and
you know deal with our issues and yeah
like if the president was doing it in
the public square and and a politician
was speaking the public square and they
said you can come and watch this but
don't you dare speak to your neighbor
well let me let me ask uh i'm gonna i'll
ask the audience for those that are
listening do you think that we should uh
inquire i say inquire because uh do you
think we should inquire about filing a
lawsuit over the disabling of chats for
public broadcasts hit one if you think
no no hit 20. because 20 means you roll
it's 20 seconds you're correct
yeah if you think we should inquire
about suing to to enable make sure that
core chat functions that are a basic
part
so let me explain i say inquire because
i don't know the law we'll talk to a
lawyer and see what they say but here's
my argument
when you start a live stream when we do
every day monday through friday not
every single day but we have to actually
choose to not have a chat
we click
disable actually they may have changed
that
no i think it's still you can enable and
disable chat but i think it's
they might have changed it to by default
be disabled in which case it's replay is
disabled by default but i think chat is
automatic well so there's the question
if chat is everyone's saying 20.
if if chat is a
it says chat is disabled that says to me
that they have chosen to remove it
i think then the government should not
have access to remove something it's a
private company youtube
uh donald trump got sued and lost over
blocking people yeah i don't think biden
should be able to get rid of the streams
and i believe that you know you know why
they disabled it because it would be
people saying we hate you you're awful
we hate you it would be funny ass it
would be hysterical yeah it would but
instead because
the public is not allowed to comment on
this and make fun of biden we're going
to have to provide that service for you
guys i'm sorry i'm i'm i am down
everyone's saying 20 so i i will
absolutely um we'll do a start with an
inquiry we'll see where it goes there
are other people who are better um
versed in this than i
and uh you know we'll we'll we'll see
what we can get out of it because
they may have changed i don't know they
like they may have changed the way they
do it on youtube which could give the
government special arguments that they
might be able to succeed in it's like
it's like when you
don't allow replies on your twitter like
at that point you've already lost the
argument at that point if you're not
allowing people to comment on what
you're saying it's because you know
you're either wrong or nobody likes you
that's an interesting question too can a
politician disable replies in canada
they do it all the time yeah trudeau's
done it uh opposition members do it
mayors do it a lot because there's no
accountability there but uh you guys
don't have a little thing called the
first amendment no and it's awful yeah
treasure your first amendment because
that i mean that's the best thing you
got from throwing tina harbor oh i mean
maybe the second first second is good
too no it's true it's true like dave
chappelle said the second is just there
to make sure you know in case the first
doesn't work out i think the first is
the first for yeah you got to be able to
discuss if the second goes wrong right
right right
yeah but then the thing is i mean the
second doesn't just protect the first it
protects all of them right that's true
it's interesting they were very
definitely philosophers the the the
people that made the u.s and i like how
they put the first one as speech and
then
i hope that we get more viewers than the
state of the union does no i don't think
we will i was just going to say the
tweet about this only got 7 000 up votes
and 2 000 comments uh no guys we do have
to we got a ratio joe biden everyone
everyone watching this share this link
you need a ratio job
so uh i'll be so embarrassed if he gets
more views than us no because can you
imagine more people wanting to watch joe
biden than you president no i just i
don't care who you are
all right you're more worth listen we
are all going to commit sudoku
we are going to play sudoku
i am deeply concerned about joe biden
being our president i guess i'll let
that put it on the table now uh so i'm
gonna i'm gonna shift things real quick
because you have a couple of minutes
maybe even one minute till the start and
i just wanna uh mention something
and uh i actually
am torn between talking about it but i
think we should and that is that we got
swatted for a fifth and sixth time today
so last night we were swatted and i want
to make sure the reason i'm bringing it
up is because there's security concerns
over why it keeps happening so
frequently and i want to make sure it is
known that we have instructed the police
to respond every single time
and to take it seriously every single
time and we also have armed guards and
we have upgraded our security
substantially and the swatting has
actually gotten a bit worse i actually
have now um i got to keep some of the
details uh vague but i was just sent
photos from our security cameras
several officers armed with short barrel
ars coming up to my house
so uh this is going to be a fun year to
put it mildly
but we talked to the cops they said
you know there's some concern about
bringing it up when it happens because
it highlights the issue
and
my concern is
what they could be trying to do is they
do a swatting
and then the cops show up and then as
soon as the cops are like okay swatting
and leave
they then come in afterwards so when
someone calls back and says help we're
being attacked they go we already went
out there for a swatting we're not going
back and that's the real attack so
that's why we we've been like no matter
what happens you get a call you show up
and they're like you got it so that's
why we keep having the police but they
know about the show so if they're
greeted that we have you know securities
is been up substantially but uh now
what's happening is this is the
interesting update
we've got foia information has been
released to us body camera footage
uh we have a name i'm not going to say
the name but the phone calls are
automated
these are automatic swatting phone calls
someone has created a bot that has we
believe it's a fake name it's it might
be a real name
but the the police have determined that
the phone calls are are
automated calls recordings
coming from california
uh the the the police have denied our
foia request on some information because
they're actively investigating what has
now become like
like the most severe felony you can
possibly uh engage in because it's we've
had six swattings it's now become
federal because we we're on the uh we're
on a tri-state border in the washington
dc area between three states and now the
swattings have penetrated uh uh have
crossed jurisdictions so what we're now
dealing with is not a single swatting
we're dealing with fbi level
federal offenses between multiple state
jurisdictions and federal offenses so
it's like it's become extremely serious
we'll see how that plays out i guess i
was told like we hear nothing but bad
things uh from from the about the fbi
especially in the right-wing media
sphere in canada do you guys trust the
fbi are they a reliable organization to
deal with issues that you
you have on like
political level i think there's a um
i've so i've i've talked with different
feds who work in different agencies
and a lot of them have said you got to
understand the culture war exists
everywhere so if you know people who are
leaning one way or the other that's the
exact same within these agencies so i
actually met a guy from the nsa
and he was like
my co-workers who are woke it's insane
but me and my my you know my friends who
work there we are not and we see it and
it's scary
and i've heard that so
as it pertains to the fbi
i think there's an issue of the biden
administration being democratic and that
giving them a lot of sway i think if you
look at under bill barr bill barr
certainly wasn't a big fan of trump but
it certainly wasn't
the same as it is under joe biden you
know the uh
i don't know if it wasn't necessarily
the fbi but we saw some stuff under bill
barr that you'd probably be like okay
and the durham probe is a special
prosecutor so there's something there
we'll see how far it goes
ultimately though
i think the interest of the fbi is
maintaining the status quo of the of the
the the bureaucratic state
so i think
based on my experience when it comes to
certain high-profile issues they'll deal
with it like any crime they're supposed
to deal with when it's political
then you're going to see politics play a
role
so as it pertains to us i think we're
probably like
on the edge of something being
substantially political to where they
would care about politics i think more
so they would just be like
wealthy dc uh suburbanite individuals
are growing increasingly concerned over
the swatting and high-powered lawyers
who live just outside of dc are angry
that they're hearing this and so whoever
is doing this is probably going to get a
bunch of dudes in full blackout gear
kicking their door in very soon because
i got some photos of something just like
that so oh boy we'll see
um and ladies and gentlemen
it is 903.
there's lakes all right someone breaking
up one of those beers you got some pens
over there ladies and gentlemen
i've finished my beer already this is
bad what are you doing
he's late we've got blonde ale we've got
raspberry wheat take three tim sheamus
ladies and gentlemen
uh all right let's see starts late start
it's already started late all right
thank you i knew but that was almost a
freebie right one more
freebie no
you take that one
the state of the union is late i'm
taking the free space
oh yeah the free space yeah so what do
you win if you win another beer yeah
another beer all right got my diet coke
i will not starts late i'm already
winning yeah me too wow i need i know i
need i need um curses that's he's not
gonna curse that's a tough come on he
does curse he might yeah every now and
again what about sonic literally
spell yeah he might actually you might
cast a smile that is the type of curse
gets mad at a fake republican what is
that it means like when he'll get into
arguments with people who aren't there
and he's like girl he'll have like some
hypothetical republican he's getting mad
at he's like i'm losing my patience with
you that kind of thing if he walks the
wrong way gets mad at a fake republican
or curses i win oh
the same one oh it's here it's here it's
here come on man you have the same
winning conditions yeah i got hairy legs
there's a lady who's that lady is she
the sign language interpreter yeah
all right does she know i love i love
this conspiracy theory that the whole
thing is uh pre-recorded
and i'm like dude there's way too many
people there for that to be the case
yeah but people were saying it and i was
like i don't know man joe biden can't
this is going to be interesting to see
if he can make it through this oh so
behind my head we have 123
live viewers
they're they're winning us we're getting
ratio
hey i'll say this we got 60 we're half
you know i i i love and appreciate all
of you who are watching us as we are
going to be listening through this i do
love you guys
and um drinking through this do we have
sound do you want to put it on the
computer oh yeah yeah tv right now
that's right oh they're back
i'm so glad this is happening
whoa whoa whoa what are they doing
oh quit banging that in my ears bro
thanks
wow that was nancy pelosi
everybody if you're upset that hurts
your ears it was pelosi who did it
thanks dance
okay we gotta watch him very closely
here yeah if he walks the wrong way i'm
so curious oh and also watch out for
inappropriate touching at this moment
yeah oh right right right yeah
inappropriate touch did you see that
that uh i think it's a news article over
there like 71 year old man
inappropriately touches girl and it
shows joe biden and then like it
awkwardly cuts away and back and he's
not it's no longer he's not on the
screen
oh man the moment you've all been
waiting for we're all here let's go come
on man
and we'll be reading your super chats
periodically as well uh from the start
of the state of the union address we'll
be getting in your comments he has not
tripped yet wow 141 000 watching now at
the white house's youtube
you know what though the fact that we're
up to happen hold on hold on
what was that like
i'm i'm trying to see if the republicans
are clapping
because it sounds like not everybody is
clapping
it's very
golf claps really waiting for those
touches you know what the republicans
are going to clap
they're you know they're they're team
players
they're classy tim yeah they're the
ukrainian ukrainian flag
i see a ukrainian flag i don't think the
democrats clapped when trump walked into
his last one i was watching a video of
it was very high energy but i don't
think the democrats were clapping and
all the women were wearing white yeah
was there a statement we are a silly
people we are a silly serious no
seriously does ben franklin tj they were
like in their 20s man well franklin was
a little older yeah he was older he was
older yeah thomas jefferson was what 26
yeah they were young man yeah there's
millie
oh that almost looked like you looked
like a stumble got real quiet
is he being guided by someone
oh
oh we should have put his handler
somewhere in here oh here he comes he
has a handler wow he's a whatever hey i
got to say like what if it really is
like a perfect state of the union with
no errors that would be awesome it's the
most famous speech ever delivered by any
president
we just look like idiots this is played
in history classes
what was it i thought he looked super
confused if if biden does not how about
this if you don't get at least five on
your bingo card you gotta check your
beer
boy no no no
i got members of congress
i have the high privilege and distinct
honor of presenting to you
the president of the united states
it sounds like she has toilet paper
dentures that was way different than how
she introduced me is she playing the
drinking game
she is the president of the united
states
vodka
okay what's happening
it's awkward 10 seconds of silence yeah
that girl on the right chat disabled
they should have put her dj on super
chat says there are a lot of empty seats
in the chain wait did he trip the
laughing face i heard that uh policy
banned certainly someone said someone
said he tripped in chat did he trip i
didn't see it because he didn't see it
it didn't happen i didn't see it
keep your eyes on the price
thank you general
thank you
thank you all very very much thank you
buddy
thank you
please
thank you so much
[Applause]
madam speaker
madam vice president our first lady and
second gentleman members of congress in
the cabinet
justice of the supreme court
my fellow americans
last year covet 19 kept us apart
this year we're finally together again
tonight oh jeez don't clap does this
count as taking credit brenden covent
[Applause]
he'll get there his democrats
republicans independents but most
importantly
as americans
with the duty to one another
to america
to the american people to the
constitution
and an unwavering resolve
that freedom will always triumph over
tyranny
i
[Applause]
epinephrine yes
six days ago
russia's vladimir putin sought to shake
the very foundations of the free world
thinking he could make it bend
to his menacing ways
russia but he
has calculated
he thought he could roll into ukraine
and the world would roll over
instead
he met with a mall a wall of strength
wrong word
you created that's not
[Applause]
the president
zlinski
to every ukrainian their fearlessness
their courage their determination
literally inspires the world
groups of citizens
blocking tanks with their bodies
everyone from students to retirees to
teachers turned soldiers defending their
homeland
and in this struggle president zielinski
said in his speech to the european
parliament
light will win over darkness
ukrainian ambassador to the united
states is here tonight sitting with the
first lady
let each of us if you're able to stand
stand and send an unmistakable signal to
the world
in ukraine
[Applause]
they just defeated putin guys
realize what just happened
she's so uncomfortable she's strong
she's resolved
not uncomfortable
on the board it's already happened
accept the free
part that's given
yes
we the united states of america stand
with the ukrainian people
throughout our history
we've learned this lesson
when dictators
do not pay a price for their aggression
they cause more chaos
they keep moving
and the costs the threats to the america
and america to the world
keeps rising
that's why the nato alliance was created
to secure peace and stability in europe
after world war ii
the united states is a member along with
29 other nations
it matters
american diplomacy matters american
resolve matters
putin's latest attack on ukraine was
premeditated and totally unprovoked
he rejected repeated repeated efforts at
diplomacy
he thought the west and nato wouldn't
respond
he thought he could divide us at home in
this chamber in this nation
he thought he could divide us in europe
as well
but putin was wrong
we are ready we are united and that's
what we did we stayed united we prepared
extensively and carefully we spent
months building coalitions of other
freedom-loving nations in europe and the
americas
america's
like many of you i spent countless hours
unifying your european allies
is it not sad that we're like well him
slurring this much isn't a big deal
we countered russia's lies with the
truth
and now
now that's misinformation right the
three
going to say it are inflicting pain on
russia
and supporting the people of ukraine
putin is now isolated from the world
more than he has ever been
together it's quote it's in quote so
it's when the word
misinformation is does kamala harris
have
only a ukrainian flag pin on
i don't know oh my gosh let me see
she's hard to see in that actually we
have a super chat goldilocks says why
are there so many ukrainian flags in the
american federal building together along
with our allies ukrainian insurrection
here powerful economic sanctions
we're cutting off russia's largest banks
in the international financial system
preventing russia's central bank from
defending the russian ruble ruble
russia's access to technology that will
sap its economic strength and weaken its
military for years to come
tonight i keep saying words we don't
understand what we know i know we know
it's an actual word built billions of
dollars off this violent regime no more
the united states this is the fake tough
guys
[Applause]
to go after the crimes of the russian
oligarchs
we're joining with european allies to
find and seize their yachts their luxury
apartments their private jets
we're coming for you ill-begotten gains
and tonight
[Applause]
russian stock market has lost 40 of its
value
and trading remains suspended
the russian economy is reeling
and putin alone is the one to blame
together with our allies we're providing
support to the ukrainians in their fight
for freedom
military assistance economic assistance
humanitarian assistance we're giving
more than a billion dollars of direct
assistance ukraine and will continue to
aid ukrainian people as they defend
their country and help ease their
suffering he sounds like he's drunk and
falling asleep i know that's when i talk
and i'm drunk and i'm falling asleep i'm
like
my words
sundown yeah it's i mean it's actually
really sad i know nothing's considered
but let me be clear it's real cognitive
our forces are not engaged and will not
engage in the conflict with russian
forces
that's a failure
i love it i'm writing it down clownfish
but to defend our nato allies
decide to keep moving west i think so i
think that's that kind of suspect
air squadrons
ship deployments to protect nato
countries including poland i've got two
more romania latvia lithuanians estonia
and as i've made crystal clear
the united states and our allies will
defend every inch of territory that is
nato territory with the full force of
our collective power every single inch
that's a fake tough guy for sure
we circled that seven times is that is
this his red line
yeah right like is it ever tiring as
americans to know that like
you're crazy you're fighting back and
it's like relying on you completely yes
well and then other countries go why
doesn't america have this social program
all the other developed countries do you
spend so much on your military because
we are your military we are your
military that's part of why we can't
afford the social programs though even
if we cut military spending
over the long run
correct thank you sheamus
ram tack super chat says is this the
state of the ukrainian address
apparently basically yeah
they've known she knows it's going to
make them sound popular to harp on this
have repeatedly shown that they will not
tolerate anyone who tries to take their
country backwards that's right to all
americans
i'll be honest with you as i always
promised i would be
a russian dictator of
invading a foreign country has cost
around the world
and i'm taking robust action to make
sure the pain of our sanctions is
targeted at russian economy
and that we use every tool at our
disposal to protect american businesses
and consumers
tonight
i can announce the united states has
worked with 30 other countries to
release 60 million barrels of oil from
reserves around the world
america 16 million 60. that's not a lot
though i'm going to crunch the numbers
because we use like
30 million barrels of our own strategic
petroleum reserve
and we stand ready to do more if
necessary unite it with our allies
these steps will help blunt gas prices
here at home
but i know news about what's happening
can seem alarming to all americans
but i want you to know we're going to be
okay 96 million barrels is that
gaslighting he's almost that's gas
gaslighting he said we're going to be
okay we are not going to be okay that's
not quite yet it's online the rest of
the world 20 million barrels a day
yeah yeah so we're releasing 16 and then
three days three days and then thirty so
that's yeah
oh no we got putin now yeah well it
shouldn't have taken
it looks like a
republican so terrible for people around
the world to see what's at stake
now everyone sees it clearly
we see the unity among leaders of
nations a more unified europe a more
unified west
we see unity among the people who are
gathering in cities
and large crowds around the world even
in russia
to demonstrate their support for the
people of ukraine
in the battle between democracy and
autocracies
democracies are rising to the moment
and the world is clearly choosing the
side of peace and security
this is the real test
it's going to take time
so let us continue to draw inspiration
from the iron will of the ukrainian
people
to our fellow ukrainian americans
who forge the deep bond that connects
our two nations
we stand with you we stand with you
putin may circle keeve with tanks
but will never gain the hearts and souls
of the iranian people
the iranian people wow
he said iranians
will never never weaken the resolve of
the free world
technically he's correct that will not
get them the hearts and minds of the
iranian people is he lying
talking about uranus and i don't think
there are people there
he's had like a super like interesting
to know
homeland proud
[Laughter]
actually acknowledged it
i understand like many of you did
my dad had to leave his home this is a
big story convenient to find work
so like many of you i grew up in a
family when the price of food went up it
was felt throughout the family wasn't he
had an impact
that's one of the first things i did as
president
was fight to pass the american rescue
plan
because people were hurting
we needed to act and we did
a few pieces of legislation have done
more at a critical moment in our history
to lift us out of a crisis
it fueled our efforts to vaccinate the
nation and combat covenant 19.
delivered immediate economic relief to
tens of millions of rich
it helped us
remember those long lines of cars
waiting for hours just to get a box of
food put in a truck
he was wealthy cut the cost of health
care insurance
and as my dad used to say it gave the
people just a little bit of breathing
room
unlike the two trillion dollar tax cut
passed in the previous administration
can i drink anyway the benefits
anyway
how else could you get there we didn't
have that the american rescue plan what
did they build working people and left
no one behind
he was talking about trump
did he actually say trump two billion
tax cut trump two billion dollars did he
say two trillion no uh yeah
we'll think about yeah
that's blaming trump
yeah but we just have something close do
we have blaming trump on here
i do not are the words blaming trump
i said that i remember if he blames
trump we didn't say trump but i think it
was your name is trump in
of jobs in fact our economy created over
6.5 million new jobs that's a lie this
is gaslighting this is gasoline this is
lighting yeah and uh congratulate
yourself yeah congratulations
[Applause]
last year the strongest growth rate in
40 years
it's interesting that they don't have
camera
shots on the republicans
are they
lower wages bigger deficits and a
widening gap between the top
and everyone else and then in nearly a
century
look that's right look fast vice
president harris and i ran for office
and i realized we had fundamental
disagreements on this but ran for office
of the new economic vision for america
invest in america
educate americans
grow the workforce build the economy
from the bottom up in the middle out not
from the top down because we know
[Applause]
those are the republicans right there
it's like a confused class literally
yeah democrats clapping
i need one more i just need two more
and now
our infrastructure is ranked 13th in the
world
won't be able to compete for the jobs of
the 21st century if we don't fix it
that's why it was so important
to pass the bipartisan infrastructure
law and i thank my republicans oh we're
supposed to drink when we cross them
right now that's right yeah no i think
i'm doing my best i need three to six
rebuild america
the single biggest investment
which one did you guys just cross
democrats only you should buy
partnerships i'm way ahead of you guys
i've just been talking to this make it
happen
oops we're done if he says january 6 i
win weeks
come on i have the same [ __ ] as you i
must
oh yeah we're both going to look
what do we win he just needs to
interfere with someone and i might be
okay that'd be
cool i'm afraid to put us on a path to
win the economic competition of the 21st
century that we face with the rest of
the world particularly china
i've told xi jinping
he's never been a good bet against the
american people it's good friends
good jobs for millions of americans
modernizing roads airports ports
waterways all across the area
and we'll do it
to withstand the devastating infects of
climate change devastating in fact
begin to replace the poisonous lead
pipes so every child every american has
clean water to drink at home and at
school
platitudes but i like the uh we're gonna
provide
this actually kind of just makes me sad
provide affordable
high-speed internet for every american
nice
gamers finally you're no longer a
president
we will start fixing over 65 000 miles
of highway and
thousand five hundred bridges he forgot
what he was gonna say that was a joke oh
he caught himself you gotta give him
that he's close
yeah
i really wanna mark it off i won't oh
look they're not clapping
kavanagh just sitting there
[Applause]
to rebuild america
we're going to do it by buying america
buy american products
support american jobs
sorry
yeah we want china to have some
government
spends about 600 billion a year to keep
this country safe and secure
there's been a law on the books for
almost a century to make sure taxpayers
dollars support american jobs and
businesses
every administration democrat and
republican says they'll do it
but we're actually we're actually doing
it
we'll buy america to make sure every
everything from the deck of an aircraft
carrier to the steel on highway guard
rails is made in america from beginning
to end all of it all of it
i like it i'm gonna credit for that one
for sure
if he does it right thompson you're
impossible but folks
to compete for the jobs
of the future we also need a loving
playing field
i love china
and other competitors
that's why it's so important to pass the
bipartisan innovation act sitting in
congress that will make record
investments in emerging technologies
it's really bad it's just normal to us
research and development is this
considered whispering you don't know
automatically i think he whispered oh
yeah i'm trying to check twist he's
whispering let me give you one example
hold on important to pass
like earlier she traveled 20 miles east
of columbus ohio
it won't look like much
but if you stop and look closely
you'll see a field of dreams i'm so
embarrassed ground in which america's
future will be built
kevin costner that's where intel the
american company that helped build
silicon valley is going to build a 20
billion dollar
semiconductor mega site i hate it up to
eight state-of-the-art factories they're
already compared to singapore you mean
10 000 new jobs
in those factories the average job of
about 135 dollars 135 thousand dollars a
year
so most sophisticated manufacturing in
the world
to make
computer chips the size of a fingertip
the power of the world in everyday lives
wow from smartphones technology the
internet technology has yet to be
invented man-made horrors be honest
right
in the field of dreams yeah
my buddy pat come on man everybody's
standing up here and said man that came
to see me and he told me they're ready
to increase their investment i don't
know who that is 20 billion
to 100 billion americans talking about
you know a defense country in america
it's gonna give us millions of dollars
back
he's talking about waiting for us for
you to pass this bill intel
let's not wait he wants a mental intel
send it to my desk i'll sign it
and we'll really take off in a big way
where's
waldo someone shouted look that's like a
pattern
i'm pretty sure it's a revitalization of
american manufacturing someone even in
canada someone with hair like that i
don't think you'll be elected that's
true just a few years ago they would
have gone overseas
that's what's happening ford is
investing 11 billion dollars in electric
vehicles creating 11 seconds
across the country also gm is making the
largest investment
gema our friend seven billion dollars to
build electric vehicles creating 4 000
jobs in michigan
all told
369 000 new manufacturing jobs were
created in america last year alone pat
gilsinger ceo of intel
intel 20 of intel is owned by vanguard
blackrock and state street
well this is fun live checking this
21 percent it's an advertisement for
intel the state powered by people i've
met like powered by intel
right generation
workers in pittsburgh who's hear us
tonight where are you jojo
there you go thanks jojo
jojo give us a few millions too
as ohio senator sherrod brown said
thanks of all the people in the crowd
oh my gosh that's gonna happen the
president should not sound this drunk
when he's sober
i'm serious sheriff brown says it's time
to bury the label rust bell
it's time
to see
what forgot what
[Laughter]
yes
but he forgot what he was saying for
several seconds
he's getting prices under control lauren
actually fell offered
faster than almost anyone predicted
that pandemic meant that businesses
had a hard time hiring enough people
because of the pandemic to keep up
production in their factories so you
didn't have people making those
beams that went in the building they
said because they were out
factory was closed
beans the panic also disrupted the
global what did he say the rust belt
needed to be called because whatever he
said is probably forgotten
look at cars last year
one third of all the inflation was
because of automobile sales there
weren't enough semiconductors to make
all the cars that people wanted to buy
and guess what correct prices of
automobiles went way up it wasn't
because of that especially used vehicles
as well but
and so we have a choice
one way to fight inflation is to drive
down wages and make americans poorer
i think i have a better idea to fight
inflation oh good genius cost not your
wages
what the hell will that do to taking
money out of the money supply jobs we
could lower inflation by lowering
inflation thank you
[Applause]
they're building a semiconductor more
goods moving faster and cheaper in fact
we're going to lose taiwan more jobs we
can earn a good living in america
instead of relying on foreign supply
chains let's make it in america
yeah yeah that's very look
we should have had stealing credit for
trump yeah economists yeah plagiarism
plagiarism
[Music]
[Applause]
what's written here is
like
that's good actually
[Applause]
building a better america
yeah we're better so this new biden
update is interesting
lower your cost and lower the deficit
building better
nobel laureates in economics said my
plan will ease long-term inflationary
pressure autonomous always wrong top
business there right they also told us
about trillions of supports
exactly here's the plan
first
cut the cost of prescription drugs
[Applause]
were these were these the same
economists
aren't sure where this inflation is
coming from
are you talking about communists because
i don't know
oh it's not economists it's a commerce
in any other country in the world that
explains it just look at insulin
one antenna
[Applause]
diabetes
which means they need insulin every
single day
that's correct it's an interesting
switcheroo ten dollars a bunch of right
wingers like
through all this i hate this country now
and now they're like usa because they've
got their woke republic george family's
like joshua and his dad up to 30 times
that amount
i spoke with joshua's mom
imagine what it's like to look at your
child
who needs insulin to stay healthy
and have no idea how in god's name
you're going to be able to pay for it is
that a fake story i don't know joshua
insulin does cost like a ridiculous
amount like i wouldn't look your child
who give him a benefit of the diarrhea
to be the parent make sure that you're
swinging kitty whispering i really mean
to think about it this is whispering
that's what i think about the cops oh
yeah
that was the whisper everybody drinks
boys
happy birthday buddy by the way obama
did that a lot biden's ripping them off
whispering
plagiarizing make things better
[Applause]
everyone can afford it
and drug companies will do very very
well they're profit margins
and the drug companies are going to do
very well let's let medicare negotiate
the price of prescription drugs
isn't this what trump was saying
prescription jugs well they're going to
negotiate the price of prescription
drugs
set the price for va drugs
look the american rescue plan is helping
millions of families with affordable
care action plans to save them twenty
four hundred dollars a year on their
health for premiums that's correct
health for premiums permanent
second that's fish in a barrel though
i'm writing them all down anyway dude
what did you call it before you brainiac
no no no no no no before the show
by combining
this man
you almost got that
you should have just put it on there
he's like to be energy efficient and get
a tax credit for it
double america's clean energy production
and solar wind and so much more lower
the price of electric vehicles saving
another
universe is the limit we're not gonna
have to pay at the pump like we're all
gonna make money and stop production of
like fossil fuels and
lauren you don't understand he's going
to stop inflation by lowering prices
to change the standard of living for
hardworking folks
just cut the cost of child care
we're going to do all just do it i don't
know
no more child care no more costs of
insulin no more inflation what we're
going to do
vote for me yeah exactly if i ran along
you know a little while to do it
i'm going to write you a check for a
hundred bucks
and i'm gonna come to your house and
bake you a cake
for your grandma
every good thing if your kids had a lot
of help though
i had a mom a dad
a brother and a sister that really
helped
but middle-class
folks shouldn't have to pay attention
i don't kind of care for the young
children
[Applause]
my plan would cut the cost
of child care in half for most families
but pay those workers more somehow
mm-hmm
parents
millions of women who left the workforce
during the pandemic because they
couldn't afford child care
to be able to get back to work
generating economic growth husbands yeah
my plan doesn't stop there at all
more affordable housing i have no idea
pre-k for three and four-year-old
all these will lower costs to families
oh more affordable housing
no one making less than 400k we'll see
your their taxes where is the outcome
well next year 400k is going to get you
about 150k
he's counting we'd all agree that the
president tax system
ain't fair
no
we have to fix it
i'm not looking to punish anybody oh
yeah
let's make corporations and wealthy
americans start paying their fair share
define fairness she's not going to
punish anyone but let's make corporate
america and rich americans pay more
that's right no punishments
fair share like chris coons and tom
carper
and my distinguished congresswoman
we come from the land of corporate
america there are more corporations
incorporated in america than every other
state in america combined why did he
just say they're more corporations
corporate americans than every other
state
the point is
yeah that's what he stumbled against so
quickly
business last year 55 of the fortune 500
companies
earned 40 billion dollars in profit 40
and paid for zero in federal taxes
that's that i don't believe it elegant
way to say 40 for somebody it's not fair
that's why i
a 15 minimum tax rate for corporations
who tax the rich socialism
how much they pay right now 15. that's
why okay
the g7 other meetings overseas were able
to put together i was able to be
somewhat helpful 130 countries degree on
a global minimum tax rate
so companies can't get out of paying
their taxes at home by shipping jobs in
factories overseas
it'll raise billions of dollars
that's why i propose closing loopholes
for the very wealthy who don't pay
who pay a lower tax rate than a teacher
and a firefighter
so that's my plan but we have to go more
detail later
i'm going to grow that's what concerns
me like i'm like i don't hate this
proposal but we're going to go into
detail so we'll figure it out fifteen
percent taxes for corporations right now
they pay twenty one percent
why are you saying minimum
[Applause]
what is he is he suggesting like they're
escaping that though by finding
loopholes and he wants to ensure that
they pay actually the 15 and while
you're at it
confirm my nominees for the federal
reserve oh come on yeah buzz off crazy
about the us
jeffrey mack super chat says has hunter
paid his fair share oh and conversely
has joe biden paid his fair share in 10
but a big guy he will lower the debt
the previous
conspiracy
conspiracy thingy it
undermined the watchdogs the job of
those to keep pandemic relief funds
being wasted remember we had those
debates
about whether or not those watchdogs
should be able to see every day how much
money was being spent where was it going
to the right place
but in my administration
the watchdogs are back we're spying on
you again everybody we're going to go
after the criminals microchips
meant for small business and millions of
americans tonight i'm announcing that
the justice department will soon name a
chief prosecutor from pandemic fraud
are you going to get this one fired too
oh yeah right
i thought he just got rid of prosecutors
yeah i thought he got ready to
investigate the independent coalition to
investigate that
i think we all agree thank you by the
end of this year the chapters have been
down to less than half of what it is
they have to be expressive that's part
of it the only president ever to cut the
deficit by more than one trillion
dollars in a single year
lowering your cost also matters
demanding more competition
i'm a capitalist but capitalism without
competition is not
capitalism
what capitalism without competition is
exploitation
it drives up profit he's talking about
monopolies isn't he yeah
and he also corporations have to compete
their profits go up and your prices go
up when they don't have to compete wait
what small businesses and family farmers
and ranchers i need not tell some of my
republican friends from those states
guess what
you got four basic meat packing
facilities
that's it
you play with them you don't get to play
at all that's true yeah this
is a hell of a lot more exactly wtf i
love joe biden
[Laughter]
moving goods in and out look at mitch
mcconnell's face
about half a dozen or less he curses
companies
[Applause]
like ask the question i mean
colloquially first usually just means
something you'd consider a swear word so
i guess it would count for most people
and as wall street firms take over more
nursing homes
quality in those homes has gone down
and costs have gone up
that ends in my watch
medicare is going to set higher
standards for nursing homes and make
sure your loved ones get the care they
deserve and that they inspect and they
will look that closely
we're also going to cut costs to keep
the economy going strong and giving
workers a fair shot
provide more training and
apprenticeships higher than based on
skills not just their degrees pork and
super chat says a lot of promises no
accomplishments yep this is a
distinction
because he's not talking about anything
that's actually exactly the child tax
credit so no one has to raise the family
in poverty
[Applause]
historic support rates i wonder if it's
going to work as well as his other
programs i think it's really cool that
biden solved every problem
tonight
calls america's best kept secret
community colleges i'm going to fix it
you just haven't done it yet
we're going to get there it's like the
guy that always tells you about that
business he's about to start yeah and he
always has like a new one
yeah i'm starting this rap album it's
gonna be huge do you want to invest in
it yeah i just need 100 bucks yeah
exactly
together we can do something we haven't
done a long time
build a better america
for more than two years
has impacted every decision the
difference between build a better
america i guess make america great again
new world order build a better america
fill back better though exactly the same
as make america great again even count
close to a million people
who sit at a dining room table or a
kitchen table and look at an empty chair
because they lost somebody
but i also know this
because of the progress we've made
because of your resilience
and the tools that we have been provided
by this congress
tonight i can say we're moving forward
safely
back to no no more normal routines no
more we've reached a new moment in the
fight against covet 19
where severe cases are down no level not
seen since july of last year
just a few days ago the center for
disease control and prevention
issued the new mass guidelines
under the new guidelines most americans
and most of the country
can now go mask free
and based on projections
convenient
based on projections
more of the country will reach a point
across that point across the next couple
of weeks
and thanks to the progress we've made in
the past year covet 19 no longer need
control our lives oh it takes credit for
running over talking about living you
have that one yeah
thank you very much thank you chris
i'm so close never will just accept
living with covington i just need
january
january 6
if he says man because this virus
mutates and spreads he's going to say
here are four common sense steps as we
move forward safely in my view it's all
stuff he wants to do none of it is stuff
he's done
what kind of progress report is that
i will do my homework effective vaccines
are
if you're vaccinated and boosted
you have the highest degree of
protection
now i know parents with kids under five
are eager to see their vaccines
authorized for their children
scientists are working hard to get that
done we'll be ready with plenty of
vaccines if and when they do i'm going
to throw it we're all ready
we we are also ready with antiviral
treatments
if you get covered 19 the pfizer pill
reduces your chances of ending up in the
hospital do you have to talk about
hypermechanics in the states
is working overtime to get us a million
pills this month
and more than double that next month
and now we're launching the test to
treat initiative
so people can get tested at a pharmacy
and if they prove positive receive the
anti-viral pills on the spot at no cost
folks
gives you the best protection but from
what variant
you know compromise perhaps some other
vulnerability
we have treatments
and free high quality mass
we're leaving no one behind or ignoring
anyone's needs as we move forward
on testing
we've made hundreds of millions of tests
available and you can order them for
free to your doorstep
and we've already ordered free tests if
you're already ordered free test tonight
i'm announcing you can order another
group of tests
go to coventest.gov
starting next week
yeah we must prepare for new variants
what happened with the last minute over
the past we've gotten much better at
detecting new variants
if necessary we'll be able to develop
new vaccines within 100 days instead of
maybe months or years
and if congress provides the funds we
need we'll have new stockpiles of tests
100 days
ready if needed
i can't promise a new variant won't come
but i can't i can't promise you we'll do
everything within our power to be ready
if it does
third
this guy's really stupid dude my twitter
feed is killing his intelligence just
lower your costs as the new just stop
being poor
we have the tools we need
it's time for america to get back to
work and fill our great downtowns again
with people people working from home can
feel safe and begin to return to their
offices josh
josh super chat saying the state of the
union are brought to you by big pharma
yep why is there intel and
kind of powered bigfoot
intel brought to you by pat in the field
of dreams
[Laughter]
man
those patriotic colors oh they're not
american
they're wearing west virginia's colors i
like that
there's 75 percent of adult 75 of adults
that's it it's interesting that on the
on the white house
it's so bad on the white house live
stream and it's not like this on all of
them uh like fox news has a move forward
image of nancy pelosi and can we achieve
this because
the white house is cut off treatment
vice president of course they could have
just panned out
sexism
290 000 live viewers and 13 000 likes
the savvy president would tell them to
smash the like button
he's not in control of his
[Applause]
thanks guys you know we've lost so much
in covert nineteen guys can you get him
to say words right time with one next
the worst of all how do you say man
i was surprised he forgot what he was
saying because he's got prompters okay
so they're focusing on joe's face i see
what you guys are doing they
i
[Applause]
i don't think he'll say trump i don't
think he'll say man either yeah i think
he might take it it's like he who must
not be not gonna say voldemort man
i need january 6 though we can't change
how divided we've been
there's a long time in coming
we can change how to move forward
on covet 19 and other issues that we
must face together
i recently visited new york city police
department days after the funerals of
officer
wilbur mora and his partner officer
jason rivera
let me see that they're responding to a
911 call when a man shot and killed them
with a stolen gun officer moore was 27
years old officer vera was 22 years old
both dominican-americans who grew up in
the same streets
that they later chose to parole to
patrol as police officers that was true
i spoke with their families
and i told them they were forever in
debt for their sacrifices
and will carry on their mission to
restore the trust and safety in every
community deserves
like some of you that have been around
for a while
i've worked with you on these issues for
a long time
i know what works
investigating crime prevention and
community policing
cops who walk the beat
who know the neighborhood
and who can restore trust and safety
let's not abandon our streets
or choose between safety and equal
justice
let's come together and protect our
communities restore trust and hold law
enforcement accountable
that's why the justice department has
required body cameras
banned choke calls and restricted no
knox warrants for its officers
that's why the american rescue plan no
doctors that you all provided 350
billion dollars
that cities states and counties can use
to hire more police invest in more
proven strategies
they're breaking with the far left
i don't like federalism
iggy says i have an app behind me
dislikes
three point nine thousand so far
messengers breaking the cycle of
violence
it could be embedded like it's like
being played on other websites we should
all agree the answer is not to defund
the police
it's to fund the police that's right
refund
they are breaking with the far left
people being screwed back he's he's
playing trump's lines
[Applause]
[Applause]
but plagiarism doesn't have to be an
exact quote often it is yeah like
stealing other people's
at this point plagiarized ghost guns i
agree i mean they were good ideas so
we've got tons of super chat saying he's
healing
[Applause]
i was gonna put gun control on here but
i thought no one cared about that issue
right now is he going to bring up
immigration
yeah i play drives i think plagiarized
he is totally interrupted
plagiarized is a is a legal thing though
so no it's like a
an educational allegedly
[Applause]
these laws don't infringe on the second
amendment oh that's a lie
gaslighting most fundamental right in
america is the right to vote and have it
counted
and look
it's under assault
in state after state new laws have been
passed
not only suppressed the vote we've been
there before but to subvert the entire
election
can it just happen
tonight appeal to african americans pass
pass the freedom of the vote act
that is john lewis
well he's got it yeah it needs to be um
and while you're at it
pass the disclose act so americans know
who's funding our election
look
i'm just honoring our
i like to honor someone who dedicated
his life to serve this country
justice breyer
an army veteran
constitutional scholar
retiring justice of the united states
supreme court
justice breyer
thank you for your service
and thanks for retiring dude so i can
fill your place yeah with an
african-american lady
thank you i think that counts
i have mad respect for people that step
down from power willingly i think that
counts though
we all know
no matter what your ideology we all know
one of the most serious constitutional
responsibility a president has
is nominating someone to serve on the
united states supreme court here comes
as i did four days ago
i've nominated the circuit court of
appeals
katangi brown jackson
one of our nation's top legal minds
will continue and just brought justice
briar's
legacy of excellence
a former top litigator in private
practice
a former federal public defender
from a family of public school educators
and police officers
she's a consensus builder
since she's been nominated she's
received a broad range of support
including the fraternal order of police
and former judges supported by democrats
and republicans
folks
if we are to advance liberty and justice
we need to secure our border and fix the
immigration system
[Applause]
i'm
so i'm like buying into everything he's
saying lauren you've had way too much
all
right
we've installed that was a non-sequitur
he was like we're gonna point to the
supreme court gotta build a wall
[Applause]
we're securing commitments and
supporting partners in south and central
america to host more refugees and secure
their own borders yeah you can do all
this while keeping the torch of liberty
who's led the generation of immigrants
to this land
my forebears and many of yours it's
almost like he's pulling a pathway to
citizens right dreamers you could be
those with temporary status farm workers
essential workers
revise our laws
so businesses have workers they need
and families don't wait decades to
reunite
it's not only the right thing to do it's
economically smart thing to do
that's why they're just like lowering
prices supported by everyone from labor
unions the religious leaders to the u.s
chamber of commerce
let's get it done once and for all yeah
what done this is
biden's gonna put like the last lego
piece of trump's wall in and be like i
did it
i made the vaccines and i built the wall
advancing liberty and justice also
requires
protecting the rights of women
constitutional writing firm by roe v
wade standing president for half of this
oh we didn't have that one anyway
we didn't
[Applause]
and folks
for our lgbtq plus americans wow
that's what i was thinking i don't care
about equality act to my desk
the onslaught of state laws targeting
transgender americans and their families
transgender it's simply wrong
i said last year especially to our
younger transgender americans i always
have your back as your president
so you can be yourself
and reach your god-given potential
god
interesting twist yeah
he's not funny well this is a christian
nation man
it's just double quote well it often
appears we do not agree do we have a
blasphemy card
we do agree on a lot more things than we
acknowledge
i signed 80 bipartisan bills in the law
last year
from preventing government shutdowns
protecting asian americans from still
too common hate crimes to reforming
military justice
and will soon be strengthening the
violence against women act that i first
wrote three decades ago
twisted logic says did they turn cern on
again
yeah right for us to show you thrown
back
to show the nation
we can come together and do big things
nathan says they know the red wave is
coming they're trying to gain some
ground
the war machines but they can only
does he think anyone who supports those
policies is going to watch us be like oh
well
the problem is definitely why vote for
republicans we basically have one in
office republicans there's gonna be
there's gonna be no action after this
speech no you're right tim biden didn't
become a republican he stated republican
talking points without doing any of that
exactly yeah exactly yeah
stop talking
prescribed but lefties will be maulding
which would be nice to lose their minds
i love the flow of illicit drugs i want
to say local lawyers
you're suffering from addiction biden is
not going to gain any republican
followers from this but he's going to
lose
his recovery
i love it 23 million i think he's going
to convert a bunch of people he's trying
to use
let's take on mental health
especially among our children whose
lives and education have been
turned upside down yeah what happened
remember when i joked that they were
going to pretend that they had nothing
to do with covid yeah to make sure your
school your school it's the teachers i
said that weeks ago
we can all play we also don't see it
coming though you know sign up to be a
should i click the dislike button
if you don't like it
i don't like
if you want me to click the dislike
button and put 20 in chat let's go
yeah accountable for the national
experiment they're conducting now if we
get to 28 000 how about we we we bargain
with them don't don't click based on
what the people want only good if you
truly believe it you just talked about a
social experiment that's conducting on
our kids
20 20 20 20.
thank you for the courage you showed i
just like what he's saying he's he's
still he's stealing from trump's time
obama protection everybody agrees
targeted everybody we're going to
children bam just come on
i don't like
the mental health services they need
more people to turn for help this guy's
gonna fix the economy give everyone the
mental health services they need every
kid is going to be we should elect to
imagine making these promises when the
country looks like this
we're giving you some time man
this is like this is like the abuse of
husbands word piece of that i'm going to
be the best husband you know just take
me back i'll be i'll be amazing i'll
support all your hopes and dreams we've
been abused by him for over a year yeah
and now he's doing a great speech being
like remember all the good times
he's love bombing
he's this far away from pulling flowers
out from behind his back baby and
playing our song she's definitely going
to hug his wife after this and on camera
no he's going to play tiny dancers that
was trump's song during his campaigns
or what's that little helping lord being
an american vacation i'm just like your
ex-boyfriend troops in iraq
don't don't go back to your ex america
i want to secure the border too
many of you have been confused clapping
i've been in and out of iraq and
afghanistan over 40 times
these burn pits did you leave civilians
there every time
medical
and hazards material jet fuel and so
much more
and they come home
many of the world's fittest and
best-trained warriors in the world
never the same
headaches numbness dizziness
a cancer that would put them in a
flag-draped coffin
i know
what is she just one of them she said 13
of them she talked about afghanistan my
son major bobite
i don't know for sure if the burn pit
that he lived near that his hooch was
near dark stuff man in iraq and earlier
than that in kosovo
is the cause of his brain cancer the
disease of so many other troops
but i am committed
to find out everything we can
committed
to military families like danielle
robinson from ohio
the widow of sergeant first class heath
robinson
he was born a soldier
army national guard
combat medic in kosovo in iraq
stationed near baghdad just yards from
burn pitch the size of football fields
danielle is here with us tonight sam
says i love how everyone is just
drinking beer
it's weird that he uses his son's death
like it's it's very sad actually that he
uses it in a way that it's like he
attributed it attributes it to his
military service that's that's weird
right not just i don't know i don't
think so i think he's probably right
about that those burn pits could have
caused the cancer
from prolonged exposure to burn pitch
yeah big time ravaged he's lungs and
body
danielle says heath was a fighter to the
very end
he didn't know how to stop fighting
and neither did she
through her pain she found purpose
to demand that we do better
tonight danielle we are running out of
beer va
what is this va is firing new ways of
linking toxins exposure to disease i
can't allow all my streams anymore
veterans get benefits and tonight
i'm announcing we're expanding
eligibility to veterans suffering from
money you don't even live here lauren
i'm also calling on congress that was
special to make sure she shows up she
drinks
that's great
finally getting the benefits and the
comprehensive
that doesn't the benefits don't save
their lives well this is also like he's
just saying he's going to do these
things he's not reporting on anything
that's gone well that's a result of his
policies because he can't all he can do
is write more blank checks or all you
can do is pull more blank checks out and
write them even though they're going to
bounce i'm glad he brought attention to
the burn pits let's end do we need more
as we know it yeah
she's going to end cancer the man is
going to end cancer inflation is worse
than it has been in 50 years 40 years
longer but he's going to come in here
and end cancer i'm writing that down
great are we going to have world peace
too joe thank you so much
if you had as much beer as i had you'd
understand with mine that's
the right amount
need nancy
lauren's at the point of drinking where
everything he says sounds good and she's
like i'm gonna vote for him
no lauren lauren's like
crazy
last month more beer is on the way i
announced the plan to supercharge the
cancer moonshot that president obama
asked me to lead six years ago what oh
our goal is to have obamacare
at least 50 percent over the next 25
years i think we can do better than that
turn cancers
from death sentences into treatable
diseases
can you make food affordable again
before we talk about killing cancer you
know food used to be affordable before
people like you decided to print
trillions of dollars the largest
redistribution of wealth that has
occurred in all of
have a more difficult time affording
food but you're going to cure cancer
before that problem's even been solved
before you've even remedied the problem
that has made it more difficult for
americans to survive you're going to
stop cancer make our
alzheimer's and diabetes yeah if you
destroy the
a unity agenda for the nation
we can do these things it's within our
power
and i don't see a partisan edge to any
one of those four things yeah if there's
somebody out there they might my fellow
americans
americans tonight he's always going to
do this in america okay well i
understand that's not here better than
iran in the field jake says drunk lauren
is my spirit animal in this capital
she's pretty well and dylan says tim
drinks like a wuss that is correct i
don't i don't drink he is a lightweight
lauren took all of the beer she asked
for more as well
no there's one left expanding another
obviously the amount of stutters this
man can get away with can you imagine if
trump did half of the amount i know the
stronger remember when he walked
the captions the captions are now
translating his errors into english into
english yes exactly when he said iran
iran testifies
they did interesting itself it looks
like his audio volume will go down and
then they won't miss this moment uh
annotations
patrick says i can't wait for the
freedom tunes episode on this oh it's
going to be beautiful this is so good
can you do a cartoon of us making fun of
him come on man well i know this is
going to have cancer man it's all done
we'll meet the test what a jerk why
didn't he do it earlier right remember
when obama re-election yes
he wasn't the president things weren't
great but they weren't nearly this bad
running for office and he's like i have
the cure for cancer and if you want it
you better vote for me it's right here
absolute animals
we faced into an opportunity an
opportunity the only nation that can be
defined by a single word possibilities
so on this night
on our 245th year
any nation
no other nation on earth has
possibilities
yeah right and my report is this not
even ukraine i would agree with that
america's number was you the american
people are strong yes i mean the
american driver today yes we are great
we will you guys
for future generations we will be great
for all time yes and welcome to america
this is your presence
and we won't have cancer this is our
moment you're on a mic dude you don't
understand we didn't overcome the
challenges of our time and we will
he's curious you're mike speaking
[Applause]
wait did he end not available
[Laughter]
we got beer can i do that what's he
doing no he's just hugging them he's
hugging people on his wife
highly inappropriate just like bite
someone's nose only inappropriate if
you're not the president just tickle
their ear man come on i just want you to
like someone a wet willy joe i think
saying hell was cursing and i think
shaking plus his hand was inappropriate
i do too yeah did you guys hear it no
that would he say he's gonna turn crisis
into opportunity like whoever's just
trying to get to biden there behind the
cameras is just desperate for attention
here uh i think that's maxine waters or
something oh yeah probably pay attention
to me joe because everyone's about to
collapse that's a very long handshake
a little inappropriately long what if he
just like as he's on camera just did a
firm open palm smack on like some
woman's bottom line well there's a woman
yeah cause he's from the 50s isn't
woman there's no footage of this but he
was accused by a woman of like grabbing
her face and then rubbing his nose up
against her nose which is like the
weirdest thing yeah weird it's called an
eskimo like just i don't know but oh
let's say they cut it off
oh
was that in that early end man right how
long was he supposed to have four lined
up i did i did yeah yes i have a couple
if cursing was was one of them did we
confirm what did he say i they censored
the word hell they censored the word so
if you had curses would you win no oh if
i had january 6th i would have by what i
wanted i was like done when he didn't
mention january 16th but you needed
curses ian i like a half i didn't know
if it was effective if we agreed i mean
like she was the only one you needed no
i need to get mad at a fake republican
yeah yeah yeah
i also needed trips and i didn't see
them fall yeah
someone claimed he tripped at the
beginning yeah i don't think so yeah he
didn't really honestly i was the most
more like trump than i guess i guess the
issue is how do we know what early was
supposed to be i thought it was going to
be longer than an hour to be honest yeah
well it was right at an hour he didn't
say man yeah he didn't say man if he had
i would have gotten a bingo for being
joe biden he actually killed it he did
pretty good yeah yeah as far as joe
biden i know yeah but for no for
plagiarizing
almost the entirety of donald trump's
platform with a few exceptions what's
the definition of plagiarize let's find
out i looked it up so it's um i think
they're afraid of the red ones those
ideas or using their words who chatted
in their theory about the red wave it's
brilliant that's it that's it that's
what he's doing i don't want to pretend
like he's plagiarizing trump because
it's important to use other people's
ideas that's kind of what humans do
collaboratively so you kind of want to
encourage it you sound like you're
talking to your teacher after they
caught you
i don't want it in the future so i'm
going to be like hey plagiarist because
i was like using a great idea from the
past yeah but this is a little bit
different yeah this is
a great again idea that he stole
the former president of the united
states who he called a nazi and i think
is the new thing is build a better
america
the name calling towards republicans who
had the same ideas is what's upset so
they're going to literally do the same
thing they're going to be like we need
to protect our border because it's
important for xyz except for some reason
when they do it won't be racist but when
we do it it'll be super racist that's
what i said because of xyz lydia all
right it's said is that what i said
canadians say that say z zed instead of
z it's weird it's one of the other
things that you know the superior
english language right
yeah i mean it was the original english
language so canadians
i remember reading shakespeare it's
written just like this eh the original
english
would it smell much different there
i don't think so we got kim reynolds
who's going to be giving the republican
response but i don't know what the
official link is just yet we're looking
for that so there's like a cnn one but i
don't want to use the bench appearance
no cnn's going to be like joe biden
presents bold interesting new ideas that
we've never heard before right give a
little response because i think we're
more effective right now with the five
of us sitting around than any any uh
news anchor let's let's do this we'll
we'll we'll do our response to uh
obviously we played the game we had some
drinks lauren had more than anyone else
yeah
made perfect sense you guys oh my gosh
too much fear
way too much alcohol i understand head
over to head over to timcast.com you
haven't already become a member if you
want to support our work we greatly
appreciate your support keeping our
journalists employed and uh
follow you can follow the show at tim
castro you can follow me at tim cast you
guys want what we'll do the our like
assessment of the state of the union
obviously we're commenting during it but
you guys want to shout anything out as
we move into that portion
that biden wants then cancer i think i
think he did better than anyone could
have possibly expected to do i think he
got a shot of epinephrine beforehand yep
like there's no way like why isn't he
like this every day like what ha what
was the difference why can he not do
this at any regular press conference
i've never seen joe biden look like this
or act like this maybe from like
speeches from a long time ago when
um when he was a young senator but
not recently well we have a super chat
here from keith he says hey tim i chose
to watch the irl show over crowder's
coverage of the state of the union uh
and then what does it say uh state of
the union address roll the 100-sided die
then talk about the federal reserve so
i'll uh i'll roll that and wherever it
lands someone can read what it says
uh it's basically on the table so what
do we get 100
[Applause]
a little too much
well we don't have laser pointers he
wants you to quit drinking something
no look crowder's awesome you guys i'd
love to pour them in right now i think
people should watch steven crowder too
thanks for watching our show but uh i
read this one specifically because biden
said confirm my federal reserve uh
didn't he say that concert confirmed if
he did it was while we were talking at
the point
you got mad his nominees
oh i thought the supreme court nominee
no can that thing no he said federal
reserve if he did say federal reserve
so he's all about fixing the economy and
that didn't work given the federal
reserve power
look i'm going to say this so you are
correct that this is basically the best
we have seen by throughout his entire
presidency but that is unbelievably
depressing the fact that he was slurring
the entire time and that's the best he
can do is really concerning the slurring
was bad but my favorite moment was when
he was like we we've chosen a supreme
court nominee who's gotten the
endorsement of the fraternal order of
the police
and she knows the law
so we're going to secure the borders
yeah and protect our country from
illegal immigration and i'm like wait
what listen he's just got so many things
he's fixing at once with his magic
powers that he's just got to like keep
moving tim i know it's too high level
for you because you haven't had enough
beers but like
you know she's just right in this stuff
you can see it it says it says 100.
100. good job rolled one it was a group
effort
tim's the tim's the four the front
runner the front man that is why i roll
somebody said that this was like a
campaign speech i think it might have
been you sheamus no no no super chatters
several of them have said how assumed
this it was totally it sounded like a
bunch of like what i'm gonna do in the
future not a state of the current state
of the union whereas like what's how
much what's our deficit uh how much
money do we lose over the last how much
money do we get back how many jobs did
we lose how many did we get back what
kind of what are the jobs reports of the
you know areas of types of jobs one
exception but to your point it was
nonsense he was claiming that we added
what nine million jobs
he said that we cut the deficit by a
trillion dollars now i'm wondering do we
raise the deficit by trillion and then
just scale it back a trillion did we he
said that at about 943 i time stamped a
lot of this stuff oh good i'm gonna go
back and re-watch a lot of it yeah i i
gotta be honest a lot of it was very
generic and so a lot of it was like i
don't even know how do you respond to
something that's just like the styrofoam
of political you know comments then a
lot of it was surprisingly
trumpian yeah right-wing trump yen he
said i'm a capitalist
but you got to have competition i'm like
well duh what do you think capitalism is
you're talking about like otherwise it's
communism you know what you know what
capitalists are always saying
competition's bad
we want the state to determine who
should be in charge of manufacturing
something because we don't like
competition i want to get away from
saying he sounded like trump because i
think trump was actually saying had some
common sense and it's not like it's
because it was trump it was just common
sense stuff to do you protect your
borders you want to build your machines
at home so that if a war erupts you can
still build your machines so
it's a good thing that they're both at
some point in their presidency focusing
on these things and maybe this will be
like the bipartisan push we need em says
can we clip sheamus speech about cancer
and have it go viral you may in fact
clip sheamus
i am officially stating that if you clip
the speech of sheamus i have no uh you
can share it just post whatever you want
yeah that means share and promote uh
cody says marjorie taylor green getting
trash talk on nbc yeah you know the
thing is
about like nbc and the corporate press
and the establishment activists i view
them as like a totally different country
and if i heard that when people in
france were talking bad about me i'd be
like i don't know why i would care about
what the people of france say about me i
don't trade in their currency or talk to
them or know much about them so by all
means be say whatever you want so for
nbc to say this stuff i'm like yeah
whatever man what about canadians look
the people the people who vote for
margie taylor green are the people who
already don't believe the corporate lies
in the corporate press so who cares if
they keep lying about her it's not is it
going to convince her voters to vote for
i really doubt it yeah if you get a
foreign complaint about something you
said that was wrong then it's like yeah
okay acknowledge that you did it wrong
and then make it good but if they're
just complaining about your behavior you
know speaking before
we should talk about what he mentioned
about taiwan when you pointed out
well a lot of super chatters pointed out
that when he was saying we're going to
build these plants to produce the chips
he was what he was really saying to
those who pay attention is we are going
to lose taiwan buckle up yep
we will not be able to defend our allies
in southeast asia china is going to move
in we can't stop russia he was just
basic look
what did he do
what this past year
what has he said
like i enacted a policy that did this
and because of it we did this
or was he like i'm going to do things
trust me we're going to start this
initiative we're going to build that
we're going to do this we're going to do
that i mean the reality is
he can take credit for some things that
kind of went away i love how he's like
trying to take credit congratulating
himself you know he's like look what we
did on covet it's like well there's the
one thing he's claiming he did even
though technically deaths are worse he
didn't yeah deaths were worse last in
2021 than they were in 2020 under trump
the vaccine was produced operation warp
speed under donald trump what does joe
biden have to claim credit for other
than an increased rate of death now i'll
tell you this
if he's going to have the if he comes
out and if he has the the
nerve to come out and tell everybody
that he's accomplished this he's going
to tell everybody the vaccines provide
you protection that was trump
trump's operation warp speed did that he
inherited this program and then had more
deaths now how does that make sense
unless joe biden was an abject failure
well there's it possibly coveted was
just getting worse it was building up
until you know six months ago or
something yeah possibly the reaction to
covid caused more damage like the harder
the lockdown more depression suicide
more people breathing cir recirculated
air no no we're talking about covet
deaths we're high i'm not talking about
um peripheral um okay so so the issue
i'm saying is if we're going to operate
we're operating completely on the
establishment narrative okay biden comes
out and says we we
we accomplish this the vaccines protect
you but trump did the vaccines if so
imagine it this way you've got a certain
number of cova deaths donald trump says
we're going to roll this thing out it's
going to be fantastic it's going to work
it's going to make everything better
biden i am giving you the tools to save
everyone's lives to make this better and
he goes all right jack and he's just ice
cream cone and then everything got worse
it could have been that like um
omicron is more transmissible so more
people have coveted in their system when
they die from a motorcycle accident
compared to other i am saying
we are not operating off of speculation
but if we operate off of the
establishment narrative biden was handed
the tools to solve this and screwed it
up anything else you want to talk about
speculation is fine what i'm saying is
based on what he is saying what he
believes what the corporate press has
told us over and over again
donald trump gave him the tools and
everything got worse it's biden's fault
period that's their that's their world
view i don't you know anything you want
to say about
you know potential
how they were how they were calculating
it incorrectly well that's not what the
narrative is from them
it's the cdc that came out and said
there's more deaths i guess they'll
argue that covert was just getting more
deadly over it was
deadly their narrative is that it was
becoming more transmissible and less
deadly according to their own narrative
the only thing i can see then is based
off of what they have told us
joe biden made everything worse yes his
administration it's not just him no and
it's the deep state the administrative
state around him that's not even part of
it i mean it's not even part of this
administration they've just been there
for 40 years you know he said that the
state of the union was strong
he said he said that things are going
great things are going great oh he did
something so great so great that like
we're gonna go cure cancer but on top of
that on top of that you know there were
so many empty promises i'm starting to
think that uh the russians will end up
getting the hearts and minds of the
iranian people right russians
oh hey can i jump in here so that was
lauren bobert
yelling out about the 13 u.s good for
her who were killed because of
negligence from biden withdrawing from
afghanistan that was pogba glad she was
there that was a surrender in
afghanistan
he surrendered to the taliban he
surrendered the us military surrendered
a war that they were winning withdrawing
was good the way he did it was bad it
was a surrender
and i i firmly believe if it was donald
trump that would have not gone down that
way you wouldn't have surrendered you
would have stayed there and then got
outside well yeah trump negotiated for
us to leave prior to the time when biden
ended up leaving but i believe he would
have done a much trump would have got to
the withdrawal date and pushed it back
if we weren't ready right
but i think
it's simple as this trump would not have
abandoned bagram air force base not
until the end that's the most insane
thing no no
what you don't let it go well it's part
of ghetto yeah no they didn't even tell
the afghan nation afghani national
security forces that they were leaving
under biden they left in the middle of
the night and told no one until uh
looters came and started ransacking the
buildings so and then the afghan afghani
army was like they did this like it was
intentional almost like they just
buckled up left
under trump that wouldn't have happened
trump would have been like
look trump's the kind of guy who's not
going to let that go down on his watch
because it affects his name yeah and
brand for him is so much i i've just
been scrolling twitter here for a minute
who was it here that said that um this
isn't going to win him any votes it's
just going to lose him the farmer yeah
it's going to lose in the far left and
it's not going to make any conservatives
looking so vash and hassan didn't
comment at all uh hassan just said that
if someone has covered in the room joe
biden is going to drop dead
and then i've seen anna casparian come
out and tweet biden doesn't get to break
about his agenda when he doesn't fight
for it and has no plan to get it passed
build back better is dead it's going
nowhere sorry's out of the union that's
the unity i was looking for leftists
hated this speech of course they're not
alone i mean i don't even think of
myself as a writer or whatever but life
left this centrist
stupid directional function
come on it's a three-dimensional reality
uh
yeah but this is percent a campaign
speech this was not a state of the union
no no one boss yeah because what is he
supposed to flex what are the
accomplishments he campaigned on coving
because he really thought that he would
be able to use um trump's vaccine to
make this all go away he really thought
it would work like he had great
confidence in what trump had done
did not pan out that way and that's the
reason he's not talked about it like at
all over the course of his speech i was
it was very refreshing to me to hear
less of the partisanship he has pushed
so hard i think he's noticing that it's
really not playing well with people dude
this is an opportunity for anna to come
on the show we talk there's been back
and forth with the young turks and tim
cast like
from a distance i want to hang out and
like dude this was crap and i know it
was crap i love anarchists i love her i
love anna casparian she i've seen her so
many times come out and like correct
herself like on kyle rittenhouse she
actually corrected herself that's right
she did come out and like call out chunk
and stuff whenever she sees things that
are good she does she is obviously
left-wing she's obviously progressive
but she does have these moments where
i'm like there's something in her that's
like not fully npc at all well i only
remember that she's better than me and
that really sticks with me well she
didn't correct that because she didn't
have to yeah right exactly i mean that's
fair okay thank you some sort of
competition anna date me
oh wow okay
and i love you i love you
i would love to i would love that van on
the show and talk about this state of
the union and what the desperation
desperate times we're in and maybe how
we can come together as a country in a
world and fix i wonder yeah but i don't
know so on but i'm not saying it
couldn't be an interesting or productive
discussion or occurred but if it
occurred but i would say that the issues
that you took with the speech and those
which she took with the speech are
probably very different i don't know if
you'll be unified i think you would
agree
yeah for sure we're saying i think you
guys would agree biden is bad but for
very different the speech was bad i'm
yeah you know i'm not gonna beat you as
bad that's the best i think it was if it
was like it felt like a campaign speech
i didn't get it i don't know what the
state of the union is now i still don't
know okay but what else okay so here's
the thing it was a campaign speech but
you didn't have an option like if you're
looking at like okay we're just gonna
try to have the most successful
politically speech we can
we can't focus on what the state of
things actually are we have to try to do
a state of the union speech without
talking about the state i know exactly
and that's what they did that was the
best option this is what we're talking
about yesterday is it ethical to lie
tell a lie like in this situation to
give people hope they don't care if it's
ethical though it was campaign it was it
was like his administration of
speechwriter they all work together and
they're like there's no way we can talk
about the state of the union the reason
yeah exactly and the reason i would
argue it's it's wrong to tell a lie to
give people hope is because then you
give them a false hope when they could
be pursuing the truth and finding a real
way out of the predicament that they're
in yeah and
i do find it kind of hilarious because
generally speaking when the country is
not in good shape presidents have just
sort of tried to gaslight the american
people about the kind of shape it is in
and pull phony statistics out and try to
warp the numbers to make it seem like
things are better than they are but it's
so
clearly horrifically bad that he knew he
couldn't get away with it or his
handlers knew he couldn't get away with
that so they just ended up having to say
well it'll it'll it will be better guys
next year come back next year the state
of the look i can't tell you about the
state of the union right now but next
year it's gonna be a good one oh boy
the question is will a speech of
promises
affect his polling
if it does because he's trying to create
a feel-good movement will that benefit
democrats in the midterms
i guess you're about to find out that's
a good question it i mean i don't know i
think
maybe i'm giving uh i i
i don't know if this is too optimistic
but i think a lot of people are gonna
watch that and they're gonna notice
which we what we did which is that
he didn't really say anything positive
about the state of the country there
wasn't anything he could take credit for
he just made a bunch of promises which
were equally as empty as those he made
on the campaign
negative about the state of the country
either he didn't really talk about the
state of the country exactly but he's
still going to come out on a win because
if he came out and was honest was like
listen inflation is a mess we've got war
in the world like we've been more
divided than ever
bam 100 percent lose
and he he just talks about promises he's
like i'm not necessarily lying listen
listen it's like that abusive boyfriend
yes
i'm not i'm talking about what i'm gonna
got you flowers i got you flowers baby
this time um so he's gonna win some
people over with that and not just have
that 100 lost so it was smart like you
can't deny that this was the smartest
best movie
here's what i'll say i agree with you
that he basically had to make promises
and in some ways he gave the speech he
had to make however what fascinates me
is that he was willing to say things
like we need to secure the border so
interesting that to me is something that
is going to lose him a lot of left-wing
voters why because the media just spent
his entire presidency telling us that
there is no problem at the border in
gaslighting the american people into
believing you are a racist xenophobe who
hates hispanic people if you think
there's an issue so his followers are
going to hear that and go oh wow or at
least the ones who drank the kool-aid
are going to hear that go oh no joe
biden's a big bad racist just like trump
i knew i shouldn't have voted for him
and i'm not gonna come out for him again
what conservative
moderate post-liberal or politically
homeless person is going to hear joe
biden say that and think
wow i guess he's finally turned around
taken the right path and now i have
faith that if i vote for him he'll do
the right thing on the border zero
absolutely how many of them will be like
well i'll try voting for trump i suppose
because i'm he tried building the wall
right
exactly well also but does i mean it
does not instill confidence in the
american people to deliver a speech two
years into your presidency which
contradicts everything that you said
would be good for the nation on the
campaign trail why do that kind of 180
unless you have been terrible yeah uh i
got some time stamps of some words that
he said possibly wrong at 9 15 he said
when he was a conflict he said clown
ficked yes
at 9 20 uh he was saying ukrainian sound
like i said uranian people think they
said iranian southerner he said iranian
he said that uh the russians will not
win the hearts and minds of the iranian
people
in fact checkers are going to come out
and say it is true there is no reason to
believe that uh russia will win the
hearts and minds of the iranian people
at 9 26 he said infects when he meant to
say effects he said
he said degree instead of agree
with our allies degree in 928 he said
loving instead of level uh and in 1934
he said
what the hell i don't know something
about the economy
was there anyone that was just one away
with uh tripping no bingo i
well i'm i'm noting here that it says
trips it doesn't say joe biden trips
like was he on mushrooms oh
yeah i guess i did win then mushrooms
outside of joe biden tripping nancy
pelosi tripped did she yes and there's a
video of her tripping
out i see hold on hold on everything i
hate to be a party pooper but the
reality is i see very well drafted
decently cartoon caricatures of joe
biden
of course ian wins on trips all right oh
okay i know right did you get did you
really get it i did i got five in a row
i got play or jurises play gold rises
all right wait wait wait let's go one by
one and explain exactly how you want
okay what each means wait ian one yeah
one trip's connected i'll show the video
that tripping i'll start from the top
well i'll yeah i'll see if i can pull it
up on twitter or something first elijah
shafer just tweeted it perfect thank you
elijah you want me uh rude i love you
man elijah is an absolute
what a gorgeous human being i love that
guy
all right let's see what we got where
where how far down 22 minutes ago uh
yeah that one oh wait is that wait watch
that nancy wait we got it we got it
hold on pelosi is gonna fall just fell
forward no she's probably wearing high
heels bro she was playing the game with
us
yeah right where is that she's always
playing the game
oh oh
that's quite the stump well i i think it
counts i think i think i think for the
sake of having a winner it counts i'm
not going to argue it you know all right
denture's flat right so the first thing
i was plagiarizing
i think we agreed he was plagiarizing
trump absolutely arguably i don't like
that terminology actually so no that's
like you think that he's using trump's
ideas but not necessarily as as james
brought representing them as a zone yes
it was the opposite of what he what he
was campaigning on before when he was
like uh you know decriminalized border
crossings he campaigned on that he's
known plagiarist he's like we need to
secure the border we got to figure out
who's flying these people around the
country man what's that if if it wasn't
plagiarism he would have acknowledged
the fact that he was wrong previously
and then his ideas came from donald
trump and he would have said the
previous president some great things
that that's right we're now falling dude
he lied about it he's taking okay so
yeah
the next one is trips
because
for weeks months we've been seeing left
wingers and celebrities come out with
takes that conservatives and center
right people and people in the middle
have been coming out with for literally
two years at this point now that they're
safe
and it's gotten to the point where we
are literally watching joe biden deliver
a state of the union where he is
regurgitating trump's talking points so
if you want to know what opinion if
you're a left-winger who wants to know
uh what opinions your leaders are going
to a spouse in two years watch watch our
show we got elijah green real quick he
says gas prices this summer will speak
louder than any promise
man i just bought a forty dollar razor
and it was fifty three dollars it was
forty dollars a year and a half ago it's
53 so that's a thirty percent increase
in two minutes
i went to the store recently went to the
liquor store to pick up booze for the
studio and i couldn't buy
yikes the prices had gone up by it
homesteading is the future
so we we like to have some some of the
good stuff some of the good whiskey
and some of the stuff i buy can be uh
well i'll just say cause we talked about
before we had papi yeah the cost of
pappy has gone up substantially we can't
get it anymore yeah it's it's like man
yeah that's uh cynics people who know
which is terrifying because the history
of war is basically unifying the food so
that your population has a bunch of
different types of you were going to say
something after the trip i wanted to
argue that racist by accident absolutely
okay so explain 100
so at the beginning i can't remember
those tim or sheamus that said we need
to judge biden by the standard he would
judge us yeah that was me right right
yeah so sheamus so he repeatedly when he
talked about the ukrainian people he
said they uh their
nation is their homeland they are a
proud people they have an iron will
their hearts and souls every single one
of these pieces would be considered dog
whistles by the splc the way he spoke to
ukrainians i can't believe when biden
and and as of battalion i thought
absolute battalion
everything he talked about that they
have a right to defend their homeland he
literally used the word their homeland
he would
he's not being racist to ukrainians he's
being a white supremacist yes by saying
that a nation of white traditionalist
europeans fight for their homeland with
an iron will are all far-right dog
whistles the splc would be like if it
was trump they'd be like look at all the
white supremacist rhetoric that came out
he's a racist never say that never a
million years ago no no but just
seriously imagine donald trump saying
the people of ukraine are strong proud
people fighting for their homeland with
an iron will yes they'd be like whoa
i don't know i'm the kind of guy
just because you see a swastika doesn't
mean it it indicates no nazism or racism
yes it doesn't work
indian wheel of time that one's
backwards
it's it's actually represents we're
judging biden off of his standard not
ours
so you can have one for me i can only
judge him off of my standards
we're playing a game okay if joe you win
you win
i'm not i'm i'm or lauren did that win
you lauren that's right we all win
because we all take a drink
all right i'll read off the rest of my
lauren you can tell me yours so the free
space then i got the forgot what he's
saying i think that happened yeah that
did happen
and then the final excited whispers
that's why is he whispering is he
whispering yeah so after tripping
there's nancy pelosi there's the free
there was the tripping was nancy the
free space forgets what he's saying and
then whispers so forgets what he was
saying there was a period where for
about five seconds he just kept
stuttering and stammering i wish we
could and he's got can we run
i can't believe it actually happened i
know i know because he hit a prompter i
was like there's no way he'll he'll
he'll forget
and he did he would he messed something
up and then you could tell in a few
seconds he was thinking about what he
messed up and he messed up more truth be
told he probably never knew what he was
saying in the first place
he was just reading the prompter and the
prompter probably jammed up and so he
was like
um come on i hope the thing jammed up i
hope that's what it was and what was
your last one whispering whispers that's
right he whispered a couple times and
then he starts going like this it's like
an appeal gotta secure the partner man
you gotta get it
gotta do it
so uh what is what is this this tweet we
have from black lives matter that's
great it says oh yes pov listening to
biden declare the answer is not to
defund the police it's to fund the
police and maxine waters just looks
totally amazing
on that one for sure oh did they really
sure did oh only people who follow black
lives matter can respond or people who
they follow
so listen listen joe biden we thought he
was going to do newspeak like latinx he
went the other way he said fund the
police
it was actually it was more it was more
trump being in a lot of ways that's
actually very promising whoever's
writing his speeches whatever this
administration is no has caught on to
something critical no it's cynical
because they're they're waiting for the
red wave i mean it's better than him
being up there and being a racist blm
like we gotta get everyone pink banners
and transgender everyone's house and
like you're like i don't understand
because he's still gonna end up doing
that stuff but he didn't at least he
i don't believe a lot i felt like he was
reading reading talking points but at
least he wasn't espousing racism
it's like there's a guy who keeps taking
a dump on your lawn and then one day
he's like he's like i'm gonna use
toilets man no no then he comes to your
house and he's like if you vote for me
i'll make sure no one takes a dump on
your lawn it's like bro that's it
got me you did it he was a dumper why
would i vote for you and you're the one
so i don't know
when biden says we're gonna secure the
border it's like yo the border is
insecure because of
you i'm not going to vote for the guy
who's making the problem
but
so you can come to me and say whatever
you want dude it's like bro i i have you
on camera pooping on my lawn all right
exactly i can smell the poop no man no
it's not zoned out
so at least it was it was good in some
ways but i don't believe him no i don't
believe no surprise i mean when lauren
screamed based at securing the borders
yeah
i think that was a third beer she was
being a little ironic although it would
be great if we could secure what does
that even mean
what he meant
yeah so i i signed up for truth social
thank you buddy oh how's that going it's
just
i got to be honest
right now the way they're rolling it out
useless
it was crazy when biden so here's here's
the here's the annoying thing right
first
and yeah one bite in one bin's like okay
it's called it's got a fight backer
against big tech
spencership it's called it's called lies
social why is that socialized
so i signed up for truth social which is
trump's thing mostly true and i'm like
number 422 000 on the waitlist oh wow
just keeps getting bigger of course um
you know they reached out and said we'll
get you on we would like to get you an
account and all that i'm like sure but i
had to sign up using like some random
like i couldn't actually sign up as sim
cast and i'm like i'm not interested in
creating some other account no and then
reaching out being like please give me
an account with my actual username so
then like after like three days of
trying to figure it out and getting
these links that weren't working i
finally get logged in because they
jumped me in front of the line to log me
in but i have some account that's not
even at tim cass and i'm like dude
ah look maybe maybe in a month when they
when it's activated for everyone and i
can actually have my username like i'll
use it feels very sloppy yeah it feels
very like the rollout they had mastered
on code and didn't give the software
code that they were using in the very
beginning which is illegal what are they
talking
can you imagine if biden at this you
know during the state of the union he
was like
and censorship it's a big problem so i'm
launching bite and dot social we're
going to make our own network it's like
they ban me from twitter man
i'll make sure you don't get banned
someone someone super chatted did anyone
else notice he was getting oranger the
longer he spoke
yeah truth that social worried me from
the beginning when they used free
software code and didn't didn't show the
code which is a violation of the of the
terms of service there's a serious
problem with there being a conservative
grift of just creating like the
conservative version of anything mm-hmm
like oh yeah
i'm going to call it a version of
twitter oh you've got like any any
anything and alt tech needs to actually
like make their own stuff and there are
a few that do it but lydia you only
needed come on man uh i needed man you
needed man so
elizabeth carmella says one more time
just in case lydia did win he said come
on man right after he talks about
securing the border rewinding oh we were
laughing yes
i believe that that's
someone is there a clip we can pull up
somewhere
i knew it i'm like you have to have said
man once yeah even like human does that
count
man
so i think
if we're going on on the truest sense of
things lydia wins because we did the
nancy pelosi tripping
he said come on just like biden you just
want to get me drunk no no no no no no
no no no no sheamus you're changing your
position it's like the american league
in the national league like there are
certain rules in the american league and
certain rules in the national the
national league is always
better helps our pitches tonight man
debatable same here i'm going to add one
more oh
say lgbt or lgbtq actually he did say qs
lgbt
that is new speak and then i win yeah
that's like a moment of silence yeah
okay there wasn't one question so we
don't we don't win okay come on and i
have the same cards
oh yeah that's brutal it's hard so what
are you going to do flip a coin roll 100
sided no no no no we we're not going to
count the 10 seconds of silence
i needed inappropriate contact shaking
nancy pelosi's hand i petition the
courts no one should do it
i thought he told a fake story to be
honest okay but the problem is like we
have to verify that later so we're going
to come back with our bingo cards
after we get a nice thoroughfare early
in the morning
take a drink
if we determine if someone else won just
kidding our democracy he didn't say that
honestly we i mean we crossed a lot of
these out a lot of these many i have
hold on one two three he didn't he
didn't play the race card yeah that was
just did not change it to trump he
didn't do that that's right
i have eleven that aren't checked so
more yeah
he did not get pulled off earlier
really well yeah well i think if we were
so so what we were doing is we were
trying to put fun ones in as well but if
we were trying to guess exactly things
he would say he would be very
predictable i think i i'm actually
embarrassed i didn't think
those were unpredictable by his general
language like most of it and then there
were those spicy bits where you're like
whoa
i mean he said he was gonna did he say
he was gonna cure that we're gonna cure
cancer
they're starting an initiative to cure
cancer the thing about cancer is the
cancer treatment is an industry so
there's a lot of resistance to stopping
it from happening and it is diet a lot
of it's dietary on top of that he did
that like he started talking about that
right after talking about inflation but
like inflation hurts
people needing to be treated by cancer
yep like like medical inflation is
actually a thing and it's a problem
especially in the united states where
you guys don't have free health care and
i'm not saying free health care is good
because it's actually awful but
what do you think about well here's the
thing but hold on biden actually has a
solution uh to medical inflation which
is to lower health care costs oh that's
right you solve that yeah yeah so don't
do that too i i you know what i you know
i just realized too there's some uh some
i mean there's some good stuff going on
here it's not it's not just about biden
him embracing border security means
those of us who for instance lauren you
want to do a documentary on migration or
borders they're not going to ban you
anymore yeah well
about that no no hold on hold on no if
they're that consistent there's still of
course there's risks i'm not saying it's
up so i'm saying they they moved back a
little bit because now
well well biden said we have to do it
look
this is a little pedantic but i actually
think this is an important distinction
he's not embracing border security he's
embracing the talking point of border
security he's not going to guys no
obama put some of the best border
policies in place and people don't
realize this because but it didn't for
them
he was his vice president they they
don't know what i'm saying as president
biden has sure sure absolutely and it's
been a lot of their language a lot of
migrants have thought oh biden's in
power and in his election he said all
these things
let in
um but you know the southern border
program that obama put in like 2013 2014
that reduced like
uh south american migrants from coming
to america by 70 percent they were
getting caught by mexican police so they
kind of outsourced it where they made
the mexican police do it and the mexican
border security but it was very
successful but obama was the deporter in
chief
yeah they say but didn't actually change
jorge uh
but didn't all right to be fair though
didn't they change the metrics for
deportation under obama's presidency it
used to be that if you sent somebody
back and then under by or under obama's
administration it was changed to
stopping someone at the border and
sending them back people say that but
i've never really i don't know i've i
i've heard that but i i haven't seen
evidence that if that was a significant
factor like oh i i think it's more so
they actually genuinely believe that
the border was an important factor but
they couldn't tell their base that so
they just they just made it so that okay
mexico we're going to give you money and
resources they literally set up like
checkpoints across the guatemalan border
like obama did this to look for south
americans coming across but you know no
one cares about foreign news so they're
like obama loves migrants so we some
canadians we have for
the state of the union response from
governor kim reynolds
but it's uh it's only like 10 minutes
long
is it cool
did it end or
ultimately for yourself
by that most important that's like a
script she's reading a script united
states that's the problem
it's only like what if someone talked to
you in that tone in real life that's
what trump did when he got elected i was
so disappointed
as a mom i literally said she's talking
to me like a mom and then she started on
the wrong track
we're now one year into his presidency
and instead of moving america forward it
feels like president biden and his party
have sent us back into this if we talked
like this on ireland does each governor
have like a response no it's just a joke
there's a biden inappropriate touching
moment no no no
absolutely
i'll let you out
hold on who did he inappropriately oh
yeah absolutely who is that woman my
guest i'm going to send you that am i
the only one who didn't i guess either
way i win lower back i win two yeah okay
whispers starts late trips man and uses
how do i open my notifications okay i
found it oh my gosh wow oh yeah i
reached i retweeted it drink some water
lady all right
i believe it's fair to say we have
inappropriate contacts yes
that sounds so bad holy [ __ ]
it's a game you know like in minecraft
whoa
who is that poor woman oh cool why don't
you do this
but the thing is like it is the most
bizarre inappropriate contact you ever
see that's not like the typical weird
chauvinistic thing to do
everybody
[Laughter]
we all won because we bent the rules a
little bit to make sure we won that's
not bending the rules this is a
certified
[Music]
because they censored a word i think
that's a fair assessment of what
constitutes a curse
yeah it was since it was censored the
white house actually censored a word he
said yes it was on youtube and they're
typing in real time so i thought that
was fair did he start democracy no no so
let me let me read you off mine we have
only democrats clap that happened a lot
uh so you know inappropriate contact
which we've shown on the screen
plagiarized like the entirety of his
speech whispers
and and curses yep well there it is so
yeah i have whispers
there's one there's one left trips
and use this fake word
i've also won dude i can't believe we
literally all wanted bingo except did
you win
who didn't win i don't want to talk
about the fact that i didn't actually
win i just got a lot of millions oh you
did
technically not it's a different kind of
but you know what i got like it all
across but if he just didn't mention
january 6 or insurrection and that
messed me up that was interesting that's
kind of when i say it could have been a
lot worse that was the kind of stuff i'm
glad he didn't ban the flames yeah he
was like giving false platitudes even
though you would have gotten more drinks
yeah
drinks yeah i have a lot of hoping for
him to scr like to do something wrong
destroy america so you can have another
one
i'm thirsty yeah like people are saying
you're not even drinking it's like
that's a good point lauren was drinking
the whole time yeah regardless of
whether biden did anything wrong i was
thinking and we weren't when he was
doing things wrong we're just talking
about it actually yeah this is unfair
this is a setup yeah
it was all right
was it was it your idea is the bingo
yeah
like i was like we're going to have a
very boring stream tonight and then
lauren was like no no that's not
happening
but uh the highlight of my night was uh
i rolled the 100. he did that
where did god roll that through your
body someone super chat had said that it
was like i've i can absorb all of the
sorcerer's powers to cast any spell i
want or something i'm here bro feed off
my passive energy who says you're the
sorcerer well you i'm like half sorcerer
half wizard stop being a sorcerer i'm
more wizard than sorcerer but i got him
both you don't have to do either i cast
magic with my charisma stop which is the
sorcery
i'm gonna cast it with my understanding
which is the wizardry
then when you combine those two you
create like a hybrid class of of magic
casting that's kind of cool like you can
do it on stage really fast all right
here's a good super chat rylo
sugar rocky says the best part about
this show is all the different views so
bias is impossible and thank god for ian
saying the most
the most won't tons uh saying the most
tons of love from canada
but most won't love that dude another
canadian commenting on american politics
stop it get out yeah it's like you know
we uh ian's like our the wild card i
truly believe magic is real they call it
comes from magnetics
and it's like
there's iron in your red blood cells so
like were these magnetic fields
and then uh what
was teed up
if you didn't know what magnetics were
you saw someone pulling a magnet or you
think it was magic he goes it is our
wild card i fully believe
when you see the human dynamo i mean you
know you know what's there well i was
just in a magnet wait wait wait wait
wait wait patrick get sucked in patrick
says biden did say our democracy at the
very end while you were all talking wait
oh come on
he's just goading me yeah is this for
real yeah that's fine let's see if we
can confirm it independently did you he
did say it did yeah but let's do we have
a more reliable do we have a more
reliable source than lydia oh okay you
cannot find a more or less then i won
again yeah well then i can't trust
anyone i just keep winning what do you
say our democracy i want to give a shout
out to our friends again over at old 690
brewing company
your beer is awesome they can get you so
drunk biden makes sense i know
it's a great selling point oh that's a
great there you go well so they're
they're in like uh mountainous virginia
area pretty close to where we're at so i
don't know what the what the politics of
that brewery is but i don't think
they're gonna be like urban city urban
liberal types alcohol and holds no
appointments
i went twice as well don't you wiggle
your car in my way look at that wiggle
your partner where do we get the second
one i gotta so uh plagiarize our
democracy free congratulate self and
racist fighters oh he was racist by
accident when was that so what we
concluded was oh the ukrainians but but
but not racist towards ukrainians like
we're retconning he was dog whistling to
white supremacists
you're right yeah
if we got racist especially because dude
there are literal nazis fighting on the
ukrainian side isn't that a whole huge
story
i have an iron will man
you know i i want to talk just a little
bit about canada about those nazis
fighting on the ukrainian side are we
going to bring out christians yeah
christian there's a photo of her she's
marching in downtown toronto and this is
you need to explain something americans
who christian freelancers is our deputy
prime minister so she's our kamala
harris her grandfather was a nazi oh wow
it's true it's literally i'm not i'm not
making this up it is true um
she lied to the media fact checkers yeah
she was actually she's perfect she's the
lady who said we need to make these
powers permanent yep yes yeah financial
yeah who's like tweaking out and
everything running oddly enough i was
sitting on a plane literally right next
door i got a selfie with her i tweeted
about it
you took a selfie with her oh that's
right i saw him she was upset about it
it was amazing she didn't know who i was
at the time but i took a selfie and and
published it and then interviewed her
afterwards um good for you anyway she
was marching in toronto uh with these
ukrainians not really she must have
known though right like the the whole i
i don't think politicians know as much
you think yeah do you think politicians
are that smart no they she would have no
idea yeah
she was holding the scarf right and i'm
like and she reads ukrainian like she's
like what what was the ukrainian message
i'll pull it up here yes can you guys
explain what the azov are exactly
they're a battalion of a few thousand
troops and then a good portion of that
battalion are like actually like nazi
affiliated so like they're they have
like swastikas tattooed all over them
and everything and a lot of people
looking at it don't understand that
there is when putin says we want to
denazify ukraine there is this like back
and forth of like you know russia has
that soviet history that you know
defeated the nazis they were the ones
that went in to
at the very end right
and then there are ukrainians that are
against russia but also like we are
white they're asian they're eurasian
they're not white like us i just read
there is that like identity um
collision that happens there but we
don't we don't understand any of that we
just are like putin's lying or or there
is the exaggeration that like all
ukrainians are nazis it's
yeah but there are people within those
groups that do believe that on both
sides so that scarf right there that's
the uh bandera movement this one right
here the red and black yeah and christia
freeland is the one in the white uh
ukrainian
dress there in the middle which one
right here yeah right there
all right and then so she tweeted that
she actually that she tweeted that
herself
whoa and then she
deleted that phrasing in the actual
tweet did she just like delete it is
that stalin that out of the picture
oh yeah look she said it what is it yeah
she literally says yeah we need to look
up what that message means but yeah i
have no idea how to look someone who's
more sober than me try to figure that
out someone who speaks or writes
cyrillic geez
i'm in the process of looking up her
grandfather's name which is not on
wikipedia you can't see her parents
names you only see they give you a link
to her uncle who was like canadian
parliament i'm sure he was
i'm about to do something really boring
that that every conservative i'm about
to point out
that if we did what the left has just
done here they would lose their minds
but of course we wouldn't do it because
it's insane this woman i mean can you
imagine if trump was talking about a
group of people who he was defending
among which there were some number of
people you could actually fairly call
nazis and then he was saying things like
they have an iron wheel
yeah ian you gotta roll the hundred
sided people are saying okay bro because
i rolled a hundred here we go
power level he's gonna roll a one
okay no 29 all right it's not bad 29.
nice prime number all right here you go
here's yours no everyone's gonna roll
the 100. the danes are going to
definitely what am i doing irish right
now
first of all the americans are going to
defeat the canadians right correct
that is so loud
you don't calm down lydia that's loud
that's funny sheamus hit it from you
today
what did i get
22 22 tim you're never going to chase
james scott it's so astounding that
you'll never see it
55.
nice dude double number yeah not bad
unbelievable i want lydia's a real
candidate yeah i can roll do you want to
roll the rainbow
how does it feel maple leaf flag i just
rolled the 99 it's bad no way you swear
to god no way i swear to god i just
rolled it to get it out of the monitor
and it rolled 99. i love 99 it's my
favorite number of the first roll again
no no i don't want to so you don't want
to mess it up the grandfather's name
this girl's grandfather's name is
michael chomiak
this is christina freeland's grandfather
yeah he volunteered to serve in the
german invasion
this is from wikispoops.com i don't know
what is wiki spooky i don't know it's
like where we monitor uh alphabet
agencies yeah it could be good
ottawa there's not a lot on the internet
about it and i don't know if he served
in the nazi party or if he was just a
german soldier there was a confirmation
from mainstream media so it must be true
that
what site was it that actually
confronted her i think was actually
american media and that's how it always
is in the in in canada we rely on
american media to actually cover our own
stuff like it was time that published
the trudeau blackface stuff wow um it
was it was american outlets that
published convoy content before anyone
like that was back when the cbc was
saying that the convoy was about like it
was protesting icy roads in canada
so if the convoy is there then it's
small and if it's not small then they're
racists and if they are actually a lot
of racists well then we need to you know
they're down they just keep
there was an icy roads protest it was
like seven trucks yeah
and then i that was really crazy because
it's a weird timing for truckers to have
an icy road to protest reading about the
deputy prime minister's grandfather
chomiak michael chomiak or how you
pronounce it it says that he's
affiliated with the nazis i think that
what happened was he wasn't in the party
from what i can tell but he was working
with me he really wanted to be with them
and volunteer he was working with them
like you were kind of forced to if
you're in the german military here's the
thing like i objectively i would not
judge someone if they had a grandparent
and and it doesn't matter to me it does
it really doesn't matter i don't care
what your grandparents did i don't care
what your parents did i don't even care
for a lot of the time what you did in
your past it's like what you're doing
now but that's obviously not the
standard they hold people to i hope they
start to because super important that'll
be very nice
i think that like when they're like if
someone killed someone like 20 30 years
ago and they're like and then they come
out today are they still a murderer we
have this discussion from time to time
like at what point do you say they're no
longer considered
they would always be a murderer well
here so
i'm not the first person to make this
point right but the reality is there are
people who are more willing to believe a
murderer could be rehabilitated than
someone who tweeted something racist in
the past could not be racist
no um but let's put this into context
with freeland right like her grandfather
was at the bare minimum a nazi
sympathizer
and then she marches in a parade holding
a flag holding a scarf that supports the
nazi ideology
and she
treats her political opponents who are
in you know in the thousands in ottawa
working class seek canadians indigenous
canadians white canadians on that other
side of a city
to a nazi flag that photographs exist of
it but nobody really saw it with their
own eyes
she doesn't get to talk about who is and
who is nazi when she marches with nazi
memorabilia and
maybe you can set her her
paternal uh grandfather she wouldn't
maternally she's maternal she wouldn't
she can talk about herself she wouldn't
she wouldn't lend you that that uh
forgiveness yeah
ladies and gentlemen it's gotten late oh
and i think it's time to wrap things up
everyone's going to have a nice pint of
uh water yeah some electrolytes explore
yeah use some vitamins before bed
coconut water
we'll we'll we'll call in the uh special
uh
iv treatment therapies for everyone to
remain hydrated vitamin drip get a
vitamin drip
nicotinamide adenine nucleotide get
healthy heal those telomeres so uh i'll
say this as we wrap up
just to follow up because um uh we
mentioned this early on in the show
about the swatting i have posted a
red partially redacted photograph from
our surveillance cameras
showing an officer with a short barreled
ar-15 approaching my personal house
which is separate from the studio
because we were i was swatted we were
swatted here and police show up we've
again instructed them to show up every
time and take it seriously every time
because the concern we have is someone's
going to call it in the police will show
up then once the police leave then the
psychopath shows up and the police are
like oh we just responded so we're like
no no matter what it is and we also have
armed guards so
um
there are some concerns about security
in terms of like my house because
there's other people who actually live
there uh and so this could have been
really really bad but everything's fine
and i posted the photo because it's
legit and i wanted i want to make sure
that everybody understands like when we
say this stuff we're not making it up
and it's really happening and this is
the i think
the uh
this is the fifth i think it's the fifth
time
because the other day was uh uh
yesterday was the third i believe today
was the fourth and the fifth that we've
time we've been spotting this one of two
houses uh as i mentioned before it's now
across state lines which makes it
federal
and we have uh a name which we believe
is fake it's the calls have been traced
to an automated system in california you
can see the photo i posted on instagram
at tim cass check it out
we're taking it seriously and um and
i'll say it again because a lot of
people are like oh you shouldn't talk
about it or whatever i'm like the
problem is
um
we want to make sure everybody knows
that we're taking it seriously and we i
want everyone to know when i say
we are currently in the process of going
through criminal charges against a man
who entered this property and tried to
use it to publicize his congressional
campaign
then put out a press release trying to
try to you know make a bunch of wild
claims and is now facing i believe it's
a felony charge and so you know we had
this conversation about like do we
really want someone to face felony
charges it's not up to us in fact we
were told by the state where we're um
i don't know exactly what what you know
what they're saying but they're like
you know charges are being filed and the
cop was like you got to follow through
because if you if you don't there's like
a precedent being set so considering now
what's going on
you show up here
we got armed guards
we've got uh the police are on high
alert obviously and you will be
prosecuted the fullest extent yo i want
to thank the police of this town and
neighboring communities you guys have
really helped i mean you guys are doing
hard really good work and thank you for
coming out here in the middle of the
night sometimes this is ridiculous but
thank you
yeah man i'll say it i'm not happy with
you know them claiming accident
circumstances when they knew it was a
swatting but i can respect them saying
we're going to rush out to a place where
we feel there could be a serious threat
to our lives that is scary i can respect
that yeah um but there but again there's
there's issues there's challenges there
look when they shut up and i i came down
and i said i would appreciate if you
would leave they said okay you know
respect and they and they left i don't
like that they came in regardless but um
you know i'm glad they're responding
every single time they're showing up and
it's a waste of their time so i was like
should we get other people commented
commented too they were like you should
get a bunch of donuts and coffees and so
when they show up they can come in
expecting oh yeah pizza
just like give some healthy foods just
order pizza before the show and they
shouldn't be like gentlemen
today we got a pineapple
pineapple pizza and then we get arrested
like oh we get pizza when this happens
guys we missed we missed one last bingo
that actually ended up being legit what
did we know i've been monitoring twitter
biden did legitimately plagiarize trump
of course he did yeah well we got yeah
did you put that down yeah did you get
an exact quote or was it
no it was just him saying like his the
entirety of his campaign was bill no but
there was like an example it was an
exact quote
so trump 2018 the state of our union is
strong because our people are strong
that's what trump says
biden 2022 said the state of the union
is strong because you the american
people are strong
so there's one word flip there there you
go there you go nice
all right everybody well i think we
should publish these and post them so
people can play along yeah they re-watch
uh let's we'll post the
when they re-watch
uh i'll take it i'll post a picture of
mine i i wrote clown fact
all right everybody you can follow the
show at tim cast irl again you can
follow me at tim cast thanks so much for
being a part of our crazy fun
shenanigans the state of the union
address go to timcast.com and become a
member if you want to help support all
the work we do normally we do members
only segments but considering we we did
this extra long special show we're not
going to have one tonight but we will be
back tomorrow um what what what'd they
say tuesday
tomorrow is going to be an amazing show
awesome
yeah i'm pumped should we i mean no
we shouldn't say i don't even know i
don't even know when i'm on the show i
don't know you're the marketing genius i
think but you've had a couple drinks
you've got a couple sips of that imagine
it was yeah nice so i've i've known
magic for uh for several years
and i interviewed him once
and then um you know we've we've
obviously like i i think he's fantastic
i think he's brilliant that guy is a
smart guy i'm really especially like
when you hear him on rogan there were a
lot of people who were like i see your
tweets and i'm like this seems kind of
crazy and then you hear him speak and
back everything up with sources facts
citations and it was amazing on joe
rogan when he was like pull up this
article and he gives him the specific
article to pull up no no here it is
here's the source like he knows and he's
got a new show coming up oh he does all
right it's on it's on odyssey i think
it's starting in like a month yeah they
got cancelled from his lbc broadcaster
so he's just going full like blockchain
done with the main stream and we've got
we've got some pretty awesome guests
coming up for the rest of the week as
well so you're gonna we're gonna have a
good week so again uh follow uh tim cast
irl subscribe to timcast.com as a member
to help support our work you can follow
me at timcast kian you want to shout out
your social media yes please um please
follow me at the real keenan on twitter
and be sure to go subscribe at uh
thecountersignal.com if you're
interested in what uh shenanigans justin
trudeau's getting up to that the cbc is
not telling you about go to
thecountersignal.com and sign up there
yeah go sign up for
kian thanks lauren yeah i appreciate it
sheamus how are you doing how you doing
folks uh i would like to promote ash
wednesday ash wednesdays tomorrow
that's right if you are catholic that is
a holy day of obligation just like a
sunday
you're required to go under pain of
mortal sin so please get out there get
your ashes represent the faith do some
penance through lent god bless you all
our country certain needs certainly
needs penance and prayers right now so
let's get it done are you gonna mention
your social media lauren oh i was about
to i i honestly i'm now feeling horrible
like this is god's curse on me for being
drunk this night
on wednesday i don't get to i didn't
actually think shane was going to jump i
was joking she was supposed to be a
gentleman and i'm not what
on instagram or twitter i i don't know i
don't know twitter that's it i check two
it's lauren underscore southern check it
out yep she's great
um what's your newest what's your newest
movie that's coming out american mirage
it'll be out in the next within the next
few weeks do you have your last movie
that you would like to point crossfire i
made that with um
the guy who's making tucker's
documentaries right now where's that
scooter scooter downey he's such a
legend you can find it on my website
southern.net yes scooter is a freaking
legend he didn't yeah kyle rittenhouse
stuff he did the generation stuff with
um you guys should interview scooter you
should yeah yeah for sure definitely
yeah scooter let's do it let's do it
follow me ian crossland.net i'll love
you guys see you later thank you guys so
much for tuning in this evening our
super awesome cool studio we never could
have done something like this during the
election but thanks to andy we have this
amazing new studio and we put all the
pictures on the side it's a really fun
conversation so thank you all that crazy
tech genius
i want to address one last super chat on
the way out oh yeah
big league drew says tim if i was on a
grand jury i wouldn't indict also tim
i'm pressing charges on a non-violent
defense ah let me clarify if i was on a
grand jury i wouldn't indict because
unless i witnessed the crime happening
i'm not going to give the benefit of the
doubt to the state if someone literally
crosses drives a thousand feet up my up
my
driveway because it's a it's an easement
with multiple signs saying you are being
recorded no trespassing you are being
warned again you're trespassing and then
literally walks in my house
yeah yeah you're gonna you're gonna
especially after we were swatted twice
lay off that dude dude tim's one of a
group there's a lot of people here this
it's a big deal so like
he's gotta prote he's got a job he's
gotta take care of like a lot of his
employees we we had james oh it was
james o'keefe and andy no right yeah and
so we actually we actually had uh uh i
want to get into the specifics but a
guest threatened to cancel because of
what that guy did correct when that guy
came in we uh uh
yeah that in the swatting and so it's
like
yeah
but but more importantly uh i'm not
pressing any charges that's not how it
works the state is doing it right so as
soon as someone trespassed we had to
call it in and the cops were like we're
doing it
that's it yeah anyway look man it is
what it is don't come here unless you
have permission do not enter the
property like we're taking security
extremely seriously we have high profile
guests we have members of congress right
and so uh i'm not a fan of having to
live this way it sucks we're planning on
doing a private club for members we're
gonna actually build a building and if
you're a member of timcast.com you just
walk in the front door like no joke
we're literally planning that of course
you'd have to drive out to west virginia
but it will be a separate property it
will be secured and away from everything
more of like
it's not a public venue but imagine
there was a public venue except it was a
private club so it'll be like on a busy
street or something because i want
people to be able i want i want to i
want life to be accessible i don't want
to i don't want to experience this this
is absurd people should be able to talk
to other people just because someone
might know who i am but you see what
happens with the threats
we have to take it seriously so that
being said
thanks for hanging out thanks hold on i
want to make a point i'm reading
actually i saw something in the chat i
want to double check um
that is saying that ash wednesday is not
a holy day of obligation i would still
encourage god it's very confusing
yeah yeah come on well hold on
check it out well it is so it is the
beginning of
lent
it's the beginning of life not a holy
place
you're encouraging people to take on
land so so it's a holy day of obligation
when you were required to i believe
there's six days in the calendar the
liturgical calendar each year that are
considered holy days
tomorrow sheamus yeah my apologies
my apologies it looks like in uh the
current year it is that is my mistakes
absolutely get over there
all right everybody on baby we are
taking off we will see you all tomorrow
with an awesome show imagine nobody will
be joining us we'll see y'all then
thanks for hanging out bye guys
you